Wir haben es wieder.
Nummern und Computerwelt, ne?
Gemischt.
Ich weiß nicht. Nicht?
Schade, weil es gibt immer wieder Anfragen. Na ja, ist ja auch egal, wie wir Fachleute sagen. Einen wunderschönen guten Abend, J.
Fritz.
Das ist das Chaos Radio 73, was wir hier zu Gehör bringen wollen an den Reglern. Wie fast immer Holger Klein und an der Kompetenz.
Frank und Andreas.
Auf den Gäste stühlen.
Auf der Gästeliste Frank und Andreas. Und an DJ haben wir auch mitgebracht.
Genau. DJ Angler, der Angler.
Der Angler.
Heute mal ohne Angelhut und sonst immer zu sehen im Metronom Club in Lichtenberg. Und spielt uns heute ja sowas.
Vielleicht vorher noch mal klären, worum es hier überhaupt geht. Womit geht es hier eigentlich?
Wir haben das Chaos Radio Nummer 73 und das geht um Standards. Also eigentlich wollen wir uns bloß mal drei Stunden lang drüber aufregen, dass die Leute alle Word Dokumente durch die Gegend schicken. Und wir dachten, wir verpacken das noch ein bisschen nett und erzählen noch ein bisschen was drum um.
Das heißt, wir spielen schöne Musik und sagen zwischendurch immer hört auf, Word Dokumente durch die Gegend zu schicken, was im Übrigen kein Flash auf Webseiten sowieso nicht. Und wenn wir denjenigen finden, der das Blink Tag erfunden hat, dann hört er ans Kreuz genagelt. Interessanterweise hat übrigens unser Ankündigungstext und warum man keine Word Attachments verschickt, doch das Interesse vieler Redaktionsmitglieder erregt.
Das haben wir doch in der letzten Sendung schon geklärt. Da ging es um das Baugutachten, dieses Rentabilitätsgutachten zum Transrapid. Das war die Sache mit den Änderungen zurückverfolgen.
Ach du willst ja gleich wieder für Fortgeschrittene anfangen. Das lassen wir mal ganz schön, wenn dann fangen wir für mich an. Chaos Radio 370 auf Fritz. Wir reden über Standards. Eigentlich wollten wir uns nur drei Stunden lang darüber aufregen, dass Menschen Dog Attachments durch die Gegend schicken. Und jetzt fragen sich Menschen. Tja, ich hab damit nicht angefangen.
Eigentlich wollen wir erstmal ein bisschen erzählen, was wir, weil wir sind ja schließlich vom Chaos Computer Club, was wir so im letzten Monat erlebt haben, was uns so widerfahren ist, was wir in den Zeitungen gelesen haben, was über die Mailing Listen kam.
Das war nicht abgemacht.
Was wir so im Bundestag erlebt haben.
Kurze Zwischenfrage, ihr wart im Bundestag?
Da sind wir gelegentlich mal, ja, besucht. Da gibt's doch netten Kaffee, da gibt's doch links ein Wollebehaus, ein nette Cafeteria.
Ich dachte, ihr hättet da jetzt irgendwie Reden geschwungen. Kohl ermahnt, wär doch mal cool, oder? Halt's Maul, genau. Herr Kohl. Und dann sagt er nämlich, so möchte ich nicht angesprochen werden, weil er will mit Doktor angesprochen werden, obwohl das glaube ich nur eher ein Doktor ist. Und ich würde mir so sehr wünschen, irgendwie mal Kohl interviewen zu dürfen, oder auf so einer Pressekonferenz zu sagen, Herr Kohl, und wenn er sagt, auf diesem Niveau rede ich nicht mit Ihnen, zu sagen, Entschuldigung, Helmut, einfach nur mal um das, aber kommt mir ja nicht zu.
Nee, wir stehen ja immerhin auf der Lobbyliste beim Bundestag.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine Liste von den Vereinen, die ihre Meinung kundtun dürfen, also sprich, die bei Anhörungen potenziell gefragt werden können, also die dann eingeladen werden können und so was wie Gutachter.
Lobbyliste.
Lobbyliste, genau.
Oh mein Gott, ihr nehmt eine Demokratiesimulation teil.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass wir da auf dieser Liste sind. Ich hatte mich nur gewundert, als ich ein bisschen rumgeklickt hab und plötzlich da Chaos Computer Club.
Da bin ich auch drauf. Ich will auch auf die Lobbyliste.
Kriegt man keine Schnittchen für.
Ist doch egal, aber kannst dich dahinstellen, einen erzählen.
Aber wenigstens kopieren sie deine schriftlichen Ausarbeitungen. Das heißt, wenn du 1000 Gutachtende eingibst, wird es kopiert. Also du musst nicht alles selbst mitbringen. Das geht dann schon.
Das ist nett.
Aber Fahrtkosten oder sowas gibt es natürlich nicht. Ja, was haben wir? Wir haben wieder viel E-Mails bekommen. Von euch leider nicht so viel, aber ganz viel Spam haben wir wieder bekommen. Und wir haben mal versucht oder ich habe mal versucht, sondern den Spam des Monats zu küren. Und da ist in den letzten Tagen reingekommen. www.religionsfreiheit.com war mal irgendwie frisch und abwechslungsreich. Und es ist eine Werbung für eine Multimedia CD-ROM, um den Koran kennenzulernen, spielerisch erfahren.
Wenn wir dann alle an Koran glauben, wird die Religionsfreiheit abgeschafft.
Also jedenfalls was anderes als irgendwie How to enlarge your penis und Herbal Viagra.
Stimmt, How to enlarge your penis, das hab ich ständig. Was hab ich denn heute gehabt? Heute hatte ich irgendwie vier oder fünf Mails, so wie üblich, hier die Fotos, die du bestellt hast, blah, klick doch mal hier auf den Link und dann schon irgendwie, blah, Punkt exe, Dingspunkt sexe, Punkt exe, was ich irgendwie total absurd fand.
Absurd, das ist ein 190er-Dialer.
Wer fällt denn da drauf? Ja, okay, viele.
Ich bin doch nur gestimmt.
War auch schön, vor zwei Wochen hab ich dann versucht, mir irgendwie so ein Tool von Hasta la Vista zu besorgen, sitz da so am Computer, surf einfach mal auf die Seite, Pop-Up-Terror, die ganze Zeit versucht, sich im Hintergrund irgendein Dialer-Kram zu installieren, wenn im Moment kommt eine Kollegin hinter mir vorbei.
Sex, Sex, Teen Sex, noch mehr Sex.
Was machst du da? Irgendwie ein bisschen unangenehm.
Ist viel besser als so ein Filter, ein Firmenfilter, für mich aufmerksame Kollegen.
Genau, aufmerksame Kollegen, das hatten wir doch auch schon mal.
Den Sonderpreis in der Kategorie Spam Ketten Mail hat auf jeden Fall die Teuro Ketten Mail bekommen.
Großartig, Christoph Kastius. Ja, ich habe sie übrigens nicht gekriegt, was völlig verblüffend ist. Ich habe dann heute mir gedacht, okay, guck mal, recherchier das mal. Und mir fiel auf, dass ich diese Mail nie gekriegt habe und muss dann so Sachen sagen wie, hat irgendwer vielleicht ein Teuro-Mail? Im übrigen nachzulesen bei Indymedia. Also wer sie nicht gekriegt hat, kann sich das nochmal durchlesen bei Indymedia.
So mit kompletter Geschichte und Namen der Beteiligten.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube, die komplette Geschichte ist da gar nicht. Also es hat eben irgendwie, also er, Kollege K wahrscheinlich dahin gepostet und darunter sind dann eben nur drei Kommentare oder so was. Also oder 20 und ich weiß nicht, die Hälfte ist wahrscheinlich von ihm selbst. Super Sache!
Ja, wer den Menschen nicht kennt, da muss man dazu sagen, der ist schon notorisch bekannt für einige andere Aktionen zum Beispiel, hat er eine Webseite, die angeblich von einem gewissen Steinhäuser erstellt wurde, die er aber wirklich selber erstellt hat, gehackt, was dann natürlich hinterher rauskam. Und wie war das erzählt?
Also das ist, also Steinhäuser für alle, die es wieder vergessen oder verdrängt haben, Steinhäuser war der Attentäter von Erfurt und Castius ist dann irgendwie zwei Tage später oder irgendwie sowas an die Presse getreten und hat gesagt, ich habe die Homepage von ihm gesperrt, denn ich bin ein Hacker mit Ethik. Und hinterher stellte sich dann raus, dass dieser Steinhäuser überhaupt keine Homepage hatte, also ist zu vermuten. Also wir können es nur vermuten, glaube ich, dass Castius das auch selber war. Nee und dann hat er irgendwie, also der hat eben, er braucht Aufmerksamkeit. Also ihm geht es auch nie so wirklich um die Sache, um die er sich da kümmert. Also teure ist ihm vollkommen Wurst, weil warum soll ich einen Laden boykottieren? Also er will ja, dass wir alle boykottieren. Warum soll ich einen Laden boykottieren, die Preise nicht erhöht hat? Der will eben Aufmerksamkeit. Dann hat er irgendwie als im Kosovo es abgegangen ist, hat er die Kosovo Such-Hotline gemacht. Irgendwie so Internetseite hat dann auch irgendwie erzählt. Ja, Rotes Kreuz ist da mit drin irgendwie, will mehrere tausend Flüchtlinge, also Familien wieder zusammengeführt haben. Das Ganze hat dann irgendwie ein bisschen Geld gekostet. Natürlich auch, weil man ja doch bisweilen ein bisschen telefonieren muss. Und leider Gottes war er ein bisschen zu blöd, sich vorher vielleicht einen Sponsor zu suchen, bevor er die Aktion macht. Dann kam ihm die Telekom und hat gesagt, gib mir jetzt mal eine Milliarde Mark oder was auch immer. Ich weiß nicht, wie hoch die Telefonrechnung war, die er natürlich nicht bezahlen konnte, weil er arbeitet ja nichts, er kümmert sich ja nur den ganzen Tag. Und daraufhin ist er dann vor gut zwei Jahren bei NTV mit einer Wumme in die laufende Sendung gerannt, hat sich vor die Kamera geschmissen und gesagt, wenn die Telekom meine Rechnung nicht bezahlt, erschieße ich mich. Den haben sie dann auch abgeholt. Nee, hat er nicht wahrgemacht, hat sich dann auch rausgestellt, dass er dann noch nicht mehr in der Lage war, sich eine echte Kanone zu besorgen dafür. Was hat er denn? Der hat doch sogar auch mal seinen Tod vorgetäuscht oder so was. Also Usenet, Castius ist der Suchbegriff, da gibt es mindestens so viele Hits wie bei Norbert Matzahn. Und dann, wenn ihr das mit uns machen wollt, könnt ihr das mit uns machen.
Es gab da eine schöne Werbekampagne oder was gibt sie noch? Und unsere Bundespolitiker haben sich da was tolles ausgedacht. Man müsste mal ja junge Leute für Politik begeistern und zeigen, dass das ja doch noch irgendwie alles so funktioniert hier bei uns im Lande, so mit rechtsstaatlich.
Hat Möllemann aber doch gemacht. Also ich habe mir direkt eine Bomberjacke geholt.
Das ist alles noch so funktioniert und da wurden dann einige Werbeplakate, einige Motive wurden dann vorgestellt. Im Bundestag und der Tierso sollte dann auch praktisch unterschreiben, dass das jetzt so gemacht wird. Dafür gibt es auch ein bisschen Geld und da sind so verschiedene Motive drauf. Oder es gibt verschiedene Themen und das eine ist zum Beispiel, dass in Deutschland nicht gefoltert wird. Das ist das, was hier jetzt auch gerade plakatiert ist. Auf Oberhöfen habe ich es gesehen. Irgendwas so mit 10.000 Watt Strom irgendwie und du musst nichts gestehen oder sowas. Und bei uns wird niemand gefoltert und niemand gequält und Inhaftierungen und sowas.
Und was ist mit dem Typen, der in Köln von den Bullentoten geschlagen wurde?
Und gewaltsame Abschiebungen gibt es auch nicht so mit irgendwie Knebel und Fesseln und so.
Ah ja, stimmt. Nee, stimmt. Entschuldigung, das ist ein kleines Tendenzradio hier.
Das Highlight von dieser Plakat, von dieser Werbekampagne war auf jeden Fall, äh, flirten, lästern, tratschen und niemand hört mit. Da ist dann so eine junge Dame auf dem Bild abgebildet, die mit einem Telefonhörer in der Hand und darunter ist dann so ein kleiner Abschnitt aus dem Grundgesetz.
Fernmeldegesetz, ne? 81 Fernmeldegesetz oder 51 Fernmeldegesetz?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, was bei uns hier auf der Datenschleuder vorne auf dem Kappau, ob das das Original ist.
Also der Original ist auf jeden Fall aus dem Fernmeldegesetz.
Dem Fernmeldegeheimnis unterliegen der Inhalt, der Telekommunikation und ihren näheren Umstände. Das ist Paragraph 85.
85?
Den verzieher laut unserer...
Okay, dann ist es 85 Telekommunikations-
Genau. Wichtig dabei ist dann auch noch ein bisschen weiterzulesen, da ist ja nämlich geregelt, unter welchen Umständen die Telekommunikation dann tatsächlich auch abgehört werden darf und das wird auch fleißig gemacht. Die Tendenz ist stark steigen, wenn man sich mal die letzten zehn Jahre anhört, was die Abhörzahlen angeht und dann gibt es dann noch eine ganze Menge von den Nachrichtendiensten, also BND, MAD, die gar keine Zahlen gemeldet haben. Verfassungsschutz waren irgendwas nur mit 42 Maßnahmen oder sowas. Und dann gibt es aber auch noch den fälschlichen Begriff der Betroffenen, der aber eigentlich auch falsch ist, weil eigentlich müsste das heißen die Beschuldigten, weil dann nämlich nur die Leute gezählt werden, gegen die sich die Maßnahmen richtet, aber nicht die Leute, die tatsächlich dabei dann betroffen sind, in dem Sinne, als dass sie zufällig, sei es der Pizzadienst, weil derjenige, der abgehört oder eine Pizza bestellt hat, dann ist derjenige natürlich auch von der Abhörung betroffen, von der Maßnahme. Diese Kampagne hat bei ein paar Politikern dann auch im Nachhinein ein bisschen zur Unmut geführt, weil das nämlich nicht das Plakat war, oder weil das Plakat nicht vorgestellt wurde so richtig, also das kam dann so im Nachhinein, wurde ein bisschen nachgelegt. Und naja, also wir warten gespannt darauf, bis die Dinge wirklich plakatiert werden. Und dazu gibt es auch entweder auf dem Cover von unserer Datenschleuder, von unserem Magazin oder auch bei Indymedia, das schicken wir mit dem Letter herum mit dem Chaos-Sticker, der nach der Sendung wiederkommt. Die URL, die hab ich jetzt gerade nicht griffbereit. Da gibt es dann eine schöne andere Variante, eine korrigierte Variante von dem Plakat.
In derselben Woche, wie die Plakate vorgestellt wurden, da gab es ja noch einen kleinen Eklat im Bundestag.
Du meinst den IMSEE Catcher? Der IMSEE Catcher, das ist ein kleines Gerät, womit ich praktisch einen Sendemast simuliere für Mobilfunkgeräte, für Handys. Das heißt, ich stelle mich da als Polizist irgendwo hin, halte das Ding in die Luft und dann denken alle Mobiltelefon in der Umgebung, ah prima, da ist jetzt meine nächste Sendemast, da muss ich mich jetzt einbuchen, buchen sich da ein, die Verschlusslung wird abgeschaltet und damit können sie abhören. Da und es dient auch hauptsächlich um diese Gesprächsdaten zu erfassen. Und die haben schon gemerkt auch, dass die normalen Abhörmaßnahmen nicht mehr so greifen mit Prepaid-Karten, die im Kreis getauscht werden oder so eine Sachen. Das klappt nicht mehr so. Und deswegen wollen sie jetzt unbedingt auch den IMSEE-Catcher haben, vor allem, um dann auch am Netzbetreiber vorbei, dann einfach mal eben schnell so eine Abhörmaßnahme zu machen. Und die natürlich dann auch richterlich genehmigt sein muss.
Sicher. Also offiziell ist es natürlich so, dass dieser IMSEE-Catcher nur anzeigen kann. Deswegen heißt der IMSEE-Catcher, welche IMSEE der Teilnehmer hat, sozusagen.
Das ist eine Identifikationsnummer des Teilnehmers.
Eine Identifikationsnummer, damit man dann auf die Telefonnummer kommt, damit man weiß, gegen wen man abhören möchte, für wen man jetzt eigentlich den richterlichen Abhörbefehl braucht. Und wenn man aber das mal hat, dann ist es eigentlich technisch kein Problem, weil der auch noch abzuhören ist. Also nur eine Softwarefrage.
Technisch vielleicht nicht, technisch vielleicht nicht, aber hat die Polizei Leute, die so ein Ding bedienen können?
Na ja, da gibt es dann ein Software-Upgrade. Du weißt doch, wie das ist mit so Technik. Da ist ein Knopf, da steht dann irgendwie abhören und da drücken sie drauf und dann...
Genau, aber die dürfen das eigentlich nicht. Naja, noch nicht. Wie auch immer. Noch ab der... Ach so, ja genau. Die können sie natürlich auch gleich anwenden, weil nämlich die Bildzeitung hat heute geschrieben, dass, vielleicht nicht nur die Bildzeitung, aber ich bin auch nicht zum Lesen von anderen Tageszeitungen gekommen heute, dass nämlich um diesen gemutmaßten oder angekündigten Anschlag auf der Love Parade, um da die Verdächtigen zu überwachen, sollen auch deren Mobiltelefone abgehört werden.
Ja, aber das bricht doch eh alles ständig zusammen, wenn Love Parade ist oder meinst du vorher?
Ja, noch aus der Abteilung Bundestag kommt die Novelle des Jugendschutzgesetzes. Da ist es also eine Folge von Erfurt, ganz klar. Da geht es also darum, dass Zugang zu Medien verschärft werden soll, Internetangebote, Videotheken, Computerspiele vor allem. Da gibt es aber eine ganz dramatische Neuerung, nämlich dass es jetzt auch eine Liste gibt, wo die zensierten Sachen oder die nicht für Jugendliche angeboten werden dürfen, die ist jetzt nicht mehr öffentlich. Die wurde also vorher im Bundesanzeiger noch veröffentlicht. Das heißt also jede Webseite, die indiziert ist, jedes Spiel, was irgendwie indiziert ist, Videofilme sind da veröffentlicht worden.
Geht es da um tatsächliche Zensur oder nur um Indizierung, dass du unter 18 nicht rankommst?
Beides. Beides. Wobei ich jetzt nicht genau weiß, diese Liste D ist das, so heißt sie wohl, ob die tatsächlich auch für diese Sachen ist, das weiß ich jetzt nicht im Detail. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Liste, also das ist ungefähr so wie im Mittelalter, wie die Kirche, die hatte dann auch irgendwo im Keller irgendwelche geheimen Büchereien, wo nur ganz erlesene Leute rein durften. Und sowas steht da jetzt auch zu befürchten. Also es ist einfach nicht mehr, gut Behörden dürfen da reinschauen, die bekommen dann irgendwie die Sachen übermittelt. Aber es ist nicht mehr wirklich öffentlich und transparent, was da jetzt genau zensiert wird und was nicht. Und ich denke, das ist ein recht bedenklicher Schritt. Kleine Sache gab es noch oder was heißt eine kleine, eine wichtige Sache, aber relativ unbedeutend im Nachhinein. Es gab ein Treffen von dem Regierungspräsidenten, ein Büsso, Regierungspräsident, oder wer ist er? Regierungs, was ist denn seine Bezeichnung?
Der Präsident der Bezirksregierung.
Genau. Ein Büsso hat sich mit dem Herr Schily getroffen und die beiden wollten sich eigentlich über die Zensurmaßnahmen in Nordrhein-Westfalen unterhalten. Das ist aber so ein bisschen ein allgemeines Palabra entglitten. Der Herr Büsso war auch bei einem Bundestagsausschuss für neue Medien und sollte da ein bisschen was erzählen. Das ist eigentlich leider sollte es eigentlich oder es hätte öffentlich sein können, aber war es dann doch nicht. Weißt du da was, Andreas?
Was hätte er erzählen? Also worum ging es da?
Ja, also es ging im Prinzip klar. Er sollte da was über den Erfolg oder die Maßnahmen erzählen. Also von den Centurmaßnahmen, was sie da gemacht haben.
Ach, hier Nordrhein-Westfalen. Nordrhein-Westfalen, ja, sicher.
Genau.
Also nochmal für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben, die nordrhein-westfälische, also der, der, der, der, was ist das? Die Regierungspräsident, Regierungspräsident ist ja, Düsseldorfer Regierungspräsident. Der hat an diverse Provider kleine Briefe verschickt und da stand drin, ich will nicht, dass ihr folgende seid, durch Last zu den Surfern, aber unter anderem rotten.com bei, glaube ich.
Ja und Nazi-Laug und noch so was in dem Stil, was ich schon wieder vergessen habe.
Interessantes Detail dabei ist noch, dass die Bezirksregierung angeblich 6.000 Webseiten hat, die sie sperren möchte, aber dem Verfassungsschutz wohl nur irgendwas in der größten Ordnung 150, 180 rechtsextreme Seiten bekannt sind. So und ja, ich weiß nicht genau, was da jetzt der Hintergrund war.
Na jedenfalls war der Bisseau bei dem Unterausschuss Neue Medien des Bundestages und hat da über seine Sensorenberichtung berichtet. Und das erste was er getan hat, ist erst mal den Beamer anzuwerfen und dann Bilder von Rotten dort kommen zu zeigen, so eins nach dem anderen, fünf Sekunden Takt zwischendurch mal Hakenkreuze dazwischen, bis irgendwann den Abgeordneten zu bunt wurden, die gerufen haben, macht mal bitte diesen Müll hier aus und ja und sehen sie und das müssen wir doch verbieten und so in dem Stil hat der Mann geredet.
Aber Rotten dort kommt macht doch gar keine Pop-ups auf Spiegel online oder so. Obwohl das vielleicht mal eine Maßnahme wäre oder?
Das konnte er dann auch nicht so richtig erklären und außerdem verwechselt der Mann ständig Meinungsfreiheit und Informationsfreiheit, also Artikel 5, das sind verschiedene Grundrechte. Meinungsfreiheit ist sagen zu dürfen, was man denkt und die Informationsfreiheit ist sich anhören zu dürfen, was andere zu sagen haben und er bringt das immer so ein bisschen durcheinander, genauso wie er Mediendienste und Teledienste durcheinander bringt, also nur eine Leitung durch die Bits durchfließt oder tatsächlich ein Server auf dem Inhalte liegen, das scheinen eben so nicht ganz klare Konzepte zu sein und ja, ist da aber nicht auch viel Gegenliebe bei den Abgeordneten gestoßen zum Glück, also es sieht wohl so aus, als ist er da nach wie vor isoliert, zumindest in Europa, zumindest in Deutschland, in Europa sieht es ein bisschen anders aus.
Ansonsten habe ich noch ein schönes neues Wort gehört bei euch hier vorhin in den Nachrichten. Die Enronitis.
Die Enronitis. Die Enronitis und das ist auch Bilanzfälschung mit Billigung des US-amerikanischen Präsidenten, glaube ich. Obwohl jetzt bei der letzten bei Worldcom hat er sich ja sogar aufgeregt. Bush hat Bush mal was gegen die Wirtschaft gesagt, aber ist ja eh Pleite die Firma, die kann ihm nicht mehr gefährlich werden.
Ja, die Telekom leitet auch unter diesen Bewertungen auch ganz fürchterlich und mal gucken, was uns da noch alles erwartet. Ja, natürlich, das hab ich ja gar nicht auf meiner Liste. Provider, kommer, kaputt, Coupé and Quest. Das Europas wichtigstes Internet-Backbone kann man schon so sagen. Auf jeden Fall so wichtig, dass ganz viele große nationale Domainverwaltungen ihre Name-Server-Backups dahingelegt haben und die plötzlich jetzt ein bisschen ins Rotieren kommen, weil wenn die Server nicht mehr da sind, dann haben die im Zweifelsfall im Ausfall dann auch keinen Ersatz für die. Da gab es irgendwie eine ganz tapfere Truppe von Leuten, die das Nog, also das Network Operations Center, das ist also die Schaltzentrale, dieses Riesen-Netwerk, die irgendwie über x-tausend Kilometer Glasfaser verfügen. Die haben bis zum Letzten haben die ihre Station, ihren Arbeitsplatz besetzt, ihr Büro richtig, haben sich da verbränkertiert, haben eine Webcam gemacht und haben irgendwie die Presse alarmiert und haben gesagt, dieses Netz darf nicht sterben. Wir bleiben jetzt hier so lange hier wirklich, bis uns der Strom ausgeht. Meinen wir es uns egal, wenn sie den Strom abschalten. Unsere Tanks der Notstromaggregate sind voll. Wir halten hier noch fünf, sechs Tage aus. Also die sind so richtig in die Folgen gegangen. Also die haben irgendwie unsere volle Anerkennung gekriegt. Einfach mal so, sie wollten eigentlich, also sie haben dann auch schon kein Geld mehr gekriegt. Die haben gesagt, okay, wir sind jetzt hier die Helden. Wir halten das Internet am Leben.
Administrote wurden ja gesagt haben, das ist unser Netz, könnte da draußen Kapitalismus spielen, aber wir schalten das hier doch nicht ab.
Genau. Bisschen was schlechtes gibt es aus Bielefeld, bzw. vom Payback Prozess, das war in der letzten Sendung haben wir darüber berichtet. Da zeigt der Richter wohl nicht allzu viel Verständnis für so eine Späße und der Fürbot hat aber auch schon angekündigt, dass er auf jeden Fall in Berufung gehen wird, falls er da unterliegt. Ja, Geschichte aus der letzten Sendung so als Nachtrag und die zwei Remotexploits des Monats sind auf jeden Fall die für den Apache Web Server und die Open SSH gerade in den letzten Tagen gekommen. Beides eigentlich so im normalen Server Alltag des Administraters würde ich mal sagen, die beiden wichtigsten Sachen eigentlich. Der Apache ist ein Web Server, der mittlerweile am weitesten verbreitete in der Welt und Open SSH ist ein Tool, die Secure Shell ist ein Tool, wo ich mich remote, also von woanders einloggen kann in meinen Rechner und da irgendwelche Dinge tun kann. Und ist damit irgendwie nach einem Web Server ungefähr das zweitwichtigste Tool des Administrators.
Ja, aber auch eine große Blamage für Theo de Raad, der Open SSH Maintainer. Das ist ein Bestandteil von OpenBSD und da stand auf der Webseite No remote exploits since 5 years und irgendwann musste er mal in the default installation dazu schreiben jetzt steht da one remote exploit in nearly 6 years.
Chaosradio 73 ist es, was ihr hier hört und das hört ihr auf Fritz.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Heute Nacht bewölkt Temperaturen zwischen 5 und 12 Grad. Morgen bis zum Nachmittag Regen und Gewitter. Danach kommt dann die Sonne raus, aber dann liegen wir alle schon in unserem Bettchen. Die Höchsttemperaturen morgen 20 bis 26 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Kerstin Topp.
Unionskanzler Kandidat Stoiber hat mehr Leistung und mehr Wettbewerb in Deutschland gefordert. In einer Grundsatzrede im französischen Dom in Berlin plädierte er außerdem dafür, bürokratische Hürden abzubauen. International werde Deutschland inzwischen mit Verkrustung und Unbeweglichkeit gleichgesetzt, sagte Stoiber. Im kanadischen Ferienort Cananesques hat das Gipfeltreffen der sieben führenden Industriestaaten und Russlands begonnen. Hauptthema der sogenannten G8-Staaten sind die Hilfen für die ärmsten Länder Afrikas. Auf der Tagesordnung steht außerdem der Kampf gegen den internationalen Terrorismus. Brandenburg hat einen neuen Ministerpräsidenten. Es ist der bisherige Potsdamer Oberbürgermeister Platzek. Der Landtag hat ihn heute mit 54 von 82 Stimmen gewählt. Platzek tritt die Nachfolge von Manfred Stolpe an. Er hatte am Samstag überraschend seinen Rücktritt angekündigt. Außerdem hat der Landtag in Brandenburg eine Neuerung im Schulgesetz verabschiedet. Das Fach Lebensgestaltung, Ethik, Religionskunde bleibt staatliches Pflichtfach. Der Religionsunterricht wird aber gleichzeitig aufgewertet. Bei der Fußballweltmeisterschaft spielt Deutschland im Finale gegen Brasilien. Die Brasilianer gewannen gegen die Türkei mit 1 zu 0. Das Tor schoss Ronaldo in der 49. Minute. Das Endspiel wird am Sonntag um 13 Uhr angepfiffen. Und die Verkehrsmeldungen? A9 zwischen Brück und Nimec ist nur eine Spur an einer Baustelle. Frei, Achtung, Staugefahr.
Ein Platzverweis.
Markos Strafraum. Marco Seifert wird mitsamt seinem Strafraum des Platzes verwiesen. Von den Fritz Studios in den Nike SubGround. Das Endspiel der Fußballweltmeisterschaft 2002 auf Fritz. Mit Marco Seifert, Kenneth M. Jepsen, Großbild Leinwinden und dir. Sonntag ab 12 Uhr im Nike SubGround. Bahnhof Kanzleramt, Paul Löber Allee, Berlin Mitte und im Radio.
Chaosradio 73 auf Fritz. Die Musik, die gerade läuft, die ist live aufgelegt vom Angler.
Genau. Und der ist unter www.antennenkinder.de zu erreichen.
Antennenkinder?
Genau. Das heißt also, wenn ihr irgendwie mit ihm Kontakt aufnehmen wollt, wegen, weiß nicht, Musikplaylist, wo er auflegt, ihn buchen wollt, wie auch immer, www.antennenkinder.de, DJ, der Angler und bald wieder zu sehen, hoffentlich im neu geöffneten Metronom Club in Berlin-Lichtenberg.
Jetzt mal zur Sache hier.
Ist ja eine Flash-Webseite.
Was ist eine Flash-Webseite?
Antennenkinder.
Genau. Thema waren nämlich Standards heute. Und das Schöne an Standards ist, dass es so viele davon gibt.
Ich glaube, der berühmte ist das, glaube ich, Dean A4. Also, lernst du ungefähr in der ersten Klasse oder so, oder in der zweiten spätestens. Dean A4.
Genau. Und dann brauchst du vier Jahre, um zu begreifen, dass nicht, wenn es kleiner fällt, die Zahl kleiner wird, sondern größer. Ist das jetzt A3? Nein. Das ist A5.
Genau. Auch noch sehr bekannt aus dem täglichen Leben ist die Audio-CD, die auch standardisiert ist. Ein bisschen komplizierter im Standard her, von einer aufgeschriebenen Sache, als so ein Dean A4-Blatt.
Aber mittlerweile ja nicht mehr, wo die ganzen Kopierschutze da drauf sind, ne?
Ja, das ist ja dann nicht mehr Standard. Also das ist eine interessante Frage, ob das noch Standard ist. Es gibt auch schon Klagen dagegen, wo Hersteller dagegen geklagt haben, weil da ist immer noch dieses CD-ROM-Logo drauf, dass es zu diesem Standard konform ist, das bestätigt dieses Label. Und da sind jetzt ein paar Leute der Meinung, dass es bei den CDs, die so einen Abspielschutz drauf haben, ist ja kein Kopierschutz, sondern ein Abspielschutz, die das dann drauf haben, das Label. MP3 ist auch ein Standard so, wobei es ja, also es ist ein Substandard, ist eigentlich MPEG Layer 1 und MPEG ist irgendwie ganz komisch, weil das ist eigentlich die Motion Pictures Expert Groups, das heißt, sie haben sich eigentlich mit Video Sachen, mit Videokompressionen beschäftigt. Aber da ist irgendwie der wohlbekannte MP3 Standard auch rausgekommen.
Genau, wo ist die Betragung? Siehst du da dieses kleine komische Pult, dieses Bediending? Da ist ein Knopf, der heißt Mute. Wenn du da draufdrückst, dann kann man dich nicht mehr hören.
Weiter links, links, links, hoch, hoch, irgendwo da. Da, so dass ich nicht rankomme?
Genau, so dass du nicht rankommst. Versuch mal.
Ja, schon besser. Besser, jetzt geht es mir schon besser.
Danke Doktor. The Doctor is in. So Chaosradio 73 mit Rolls-Royce-Taste. Wir reden über Standards.
Genau.
Können wir damit denn jetzt mal anfangen?
Nein, ich muss wieder. Also Standards sind eigentlich eine ganz alte Sache. Die ist dann so im Zuge der Industrialisierung entstanden und das fing so ganz harmlos an mit Schrauben, weil man wollte irgendwie Maschinen zusammenschrauben und hat dann gemerkt, dass es eigentlich blöd ist, diese ganzen Schrauben immer selbst zu machen. Und dann gab es auch schon die erste Gedanken von Outsourcing, also dass jemand anders die Schrauben dann herstellt und anliefert, termingerecht. Und irgendwie musste ich eben noch beschreiben, wie diese Schrauben aussehen sollten. Und dann ist man auf die Idee gekommen, dass es ja auch praktisch wäre, wenn man Ersatzteile irgendwo mal, ja, irgendwo schnell mal nachkaufen kann, die vielleicht irgendwo vorrätig sind, sei es für irgendwelche Fuhrwerke oder Kutschen oder spätestens dann bei den Autos. Und so haben sich dann so Industrienormen entwickelt. Das heißt, wo dann gesagt hat, wenn die Schraube irgendwie, wenn die M5 heißt, dann soll die irgendwie Durchmesser von 5 Millimeter haben und dies und jenes. Und das war eigentlich so die erste Idee. Ein bisschen später sind dann Sicherheitsrichtlinien gekommen als Normung für Dampfkessel zum Beispiel. Das heißt also auch schon der TÜV, der Technische Überwachungsverein hat dann schon Dampfkessel geprüft und geschaut, ob den irgendwelchen Sicherheitsstandard, also den Berstdruck und so eine Sachen, Außentemperatur entsprechen. Das waren eigentlich so die ersten Normen, in dem Sinne, die entstanden sind.
Also das Bedürfnis, dass man über dasselbe redet, wenn man Waren miteinander vergleicht, ist ja schon ein bisschen älter. So Maße und Gewichte sind sicherlich das, was im kleinen Kalender immer, ne?
Meterelle, es gab früher mal die Elle zum Beispiel als Maß.
Das war natürlich auch überall verschieden, weil die Elle der Könige natürlich überall verschieden lang war und das musste ja schon irgendwie passen und...
Ich meine, es gab doch sogar früher auch deutschlandweit unterschiedliche Urzeiten.
Ja, die jetzigen Zeitzonen wurden als Eisenbahnzeit eingeführt, weil vorher reichte halt der Sonnenstand aus, so schnell hat man sich nicht von A nach B bewegt, dass man die Zeit da hätte vergleichen müssen. Zeitstandards, ja die Einteilung des Tages in 24 Stunden, Kalender sind eigentlich auch Standards, nämlich dafür, wie man die Tage zählt und die Monate und die Jahre, aber das war halt relativ wenig, das waren so ein paar grundlegende Einheiten, die da standalisiert waren und die richtige Explosion ist erst mit der industriellen Revolution gekommen, als plötzlich jeder Kleingraben, jeder vorzustellen, die sie werden mussten, bis zum Malzbonbon und den Kondomlängen heutzutage.
Und Kompressionsstrüffe sind Strümpfe sind auch definiert, zum Beispiel bezeichnet V etwa den Druckverlauf des Strümpfes entlang des Beines und dann gibt es noch den Übergang dann nach oben und dafür gibt es dann zum Beispiel eine europäische CE-Norm, was also für den freien Warenverkehr innerhalb von Europa sinnvoll ist, dass dann auch alle Hersteller vom gleichen sprechen und dass die Sachen kompatibel sind, wie man so schön sagt.
Das heißt, wenn du an Normierung denkst, denkst du an Kompressionsstrümpfe?
Ja oder zum Beispiel an Kondome. Es hat sich auch eine ganze Weile hingezogen, die Diskussion, wie lang denn jetzt ein europäisches Standardkondom ist, weil die, ich glaub die Spanier haben irgendwie 18 Zentimeter Durchschnittslänge und die Großbritannien, also die Engländer haben irgendwas mit 16 oder sowas, Deutschland nicht mit 17, 2, sowas in der Größenordnung, so im Mittelfeld.
Das können wir uns ja nachher mal von Hörerinnen bestätigen lassen, oder?
Ich glaube, es liegt eher daran, wie groß der Landesweitedurchschnitt im Übertreiben ist.
Ah, mein Kompressionsstrumpf zwickt. Frank, müssen wir uns mal irgendwie unterhalten? Also ich mein gesondert?
Über Kompressionsstrüffen oder die Durchschnittsläufe?
Wir können uns auch gerne, also wenn du möchtest, Frank, dann können wir auch gerne über Kompressionsstrümpfe reden. Wir können da alles reden, was du möchtest.
Ich hab das beim Klicken gefunden. Es ist ja mal so dieses, du suchst ja irgendwie einen Begriff von bei Google und denkst, das sieht jetzt aber interessant aus. Hast du mal versucht mit Kompressionsstrümpf Google Working zu machen? Nein, das war auf der SAP Anwenderseite, Website, wo es irgendwie um, darum ging irgendwie SAP als besonders flexibles System zu bewerben.
Kompressionsstrümpfe.
Da war dieses Beispiel.
Kein Wunder, dass die Probleme mit ihrer Software haben.
Wir wollten jetzt mal so ein paar Abkürzungen.
Mehr Beispiele für Standards, wo wir gerade bei fahrischen Objekten sind.
Waren wir das? Mein Bein ist ein fallisches Objekt.
Es gibt Prüffinger für Telefone. Du, also es ging.
Prüfe Finger für Telefone.
Ja, kein Scheiß. Ich meine, wenn man so eine Telefonzelle auf öffentliches Straßenland stellt, dann muss das auch alles seine Ordnung haben. Und deswegen prüft die für die zuständige Abnahme zuständige Situation mithilfe eines Metallfingers, ob wenn man auf die eine Taste draufdrückt, man nicht aus Versehen auch die andere Taste ausriss. Es ist halt so ein Stückchen Metall, so ein etwas breiterer, schon relativ klobiger Finger. Also so eine Popperfunke von heute kann man damit nicht bedienen.
Kann da nicht einfach in die Telefonzelle gehen und mal auf den Knopf drücken?
Bei Ikea gibt es doch sowas auch. Kennst du nicht im Eingangsbereich?
Was ich auch gesehen habe bei diesen WM-Fußbällen, die haben Maschinen, die schießen den Ball durch irgendwie so ein Ding durch. Ja fällt mir noch ein. Nein, durch so ein Schlauch praktisch. Und der muss dann genau die Flugbahn durch diesen gebogenen Schlauch, also ein ballistisch gebogener Schlauch, wenn du so willst. Und da musst du ja genau durchpassen, weil da gibt es auch einen Schießautomaten, der immer mit demselben Druck schießt.
Was sind das eigentlich für Leute, die sich sowas alles ausdenken, wie Prüffinger oder so, die heißen in Deutschland VDE DIN TÜV ZKI. Das sind so ganz sexy Abkürzungen.
Zentralkomitee Industrienorm.
Das sind die, die die Geldkarte machen, diese Sachen im Zahlungsbereich normieren. TÜV, klar, kennt jeder irgendwie vom Auto. So, die sind halt für den ganzen technischen Kram, machen jetzt auch Software, zertifizieren sie.
Also da, wo ich TÜV kriege für wenig Geld, da ist nichts mit Software.
Du kannst ja mal probieren, zur TÜV-Stelle mit deinem Windows zu gehen. Das ist das Deutsche Institut für Normung, die durch die DIN A4-Seite berühmt geworden sind. Und es gibt übrigens auch analog dazu den Grauart Brief. Das ist, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine VDE-Norm ist. Das ist ein Test, um Faxgeräte und Drucker zu testen, also die Geschwindigkeit, die Verarbeitungsgeschwindigkeit, wie so eine Seite ausgedruckt wird. Das ist einfach ein Brief, der hat der Grauart, wir bestellen bei Ihnen Talhara für irgendwas.
Ach so, ich dachte, das wäre ein grauer Brief.
Also ein Grauart.
Ja, ja, ich hab das missverstanden.
Na es geht schon dabei drum, dass dieser Brief genau 5% Grauabdeckung hat. Ach so.
So schwarz.
Ja, sozusagen ein Insiderwitz von Standardmachern.
Lustige Typen, ne?
Kannst dich förmlich vorstellen.
Mit ihren Ärmel schonern sitzen und ja.
Ja, Schrauben nach Normengröße. Ja, ein großes Problem mit den Standards ist ja immer, dass es so viele davon gibt und da geht das zum Beispiel los, dass wir jetzt deutsche Normungsinstitute haben, aber mittlerweile auch europäische und weltweite. Dann gibt es nicht nur Normungsinstitute, sondern gibt es auch Firmen, die beschließen ihre eigenen Standards, die sich dann durchsetzen oder auch Firmenkonsorten, die sich zusammentun und einfach sagen, wir machen das jetzt, ohne dass da ein Gremium dahinter stehen würde. Und ja, die Standards sind dadurch auch alle nicht gleich. Also dadurch, dass irgendjemand anders das genauso macht, ist es noch lange kein wünschenswerter Standard, sondern Standards teilen sich auch nach Eigenschaften auf, wie ist das ein offener Standard? Das heißt, kann man den einfach nachbauen, wenn man das möchte? Kann man ihn überhaupt umsonst runterladen oder muss man Geld dafür ausgeben? Muss man vielleicht noch irgendwelche Patente dazu kaufen, wenn man das bauen will? Gibt es überhaupt irgendjemand anders, der das bauen darf oder kommt das alles nur von demselben Hersteller? Und da sind wir wieder bei Microsoft, weil die fallen in die letztere Kategorie. Die standardisieren ihre Produkte. Das heißt, irgendwie so ein Word-Dokument ist halt definiert als etwas, was von Microsoft Word geladen werden kann. Da gibt es also kein Dokument, wo drin steht, ein Word-File sieht so aus, Doppelpunkt, fängt mit einer 23 an und hört mit einer 42 auf. Sondern es ist einfach definiert dadurch, dass man es mit Word aufmachen kann. Und das ist natürlich nicht besonders toll für Leute, die auch ein Programm programmieren wollen, um das anzuzeigen, vielleicht weil man mal ein Word-Dokument auf einen anderen Computer schicken will, wo es gar kein Word gibt. Und deswegen ist das so ein Standard, den man eigentlich boykottieren sollte, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, einen wirklich offenen Standard zu verwenden. Also ein offener, weltweiter Standard, das ist immer so das, wovon alle träumen, alle sind interoperabel, alle können miteinander. Und in Wirklichkeit, wenn ich Standards häufig dazu benutze, Firmeninteressen durchzusetzen, Machtspielchen zu spielen und nebenbei noch ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen.
Wobei das mit dem Boykott eigentlich ja schon gar nicht mal gerechtfertigt ist. Das ist ja nur eine, ich tue ja dem anderen was Gutes. Oder, also ich rechne damit, dass er nicht unbedingt irgendwie jetzt das 1000 Mark teure Office-Paket von Microsoft gekauft hat, sondern ich schicke ihm, was er mit Sicherheit aufmachen kann oder was er auf jeden Fall auch dann aufmachen kann. Wenn er zum Beispiel gerade keinen Windows-PC hat, sondern einen Mac oder vielleicht ein Unix-System oder was auch immer und eben keine teures Software extra gekauft haben muss, um die Sachen anzugucken. Deswegen ist das, deswegen ist Boykott irgendwie jetzt nicht, also klar, also ich kann es natürlich generell boykottieren.
Du meinst den Versand oder den Empfang, wenn dir so was jemand als E-Mail schickt?
Ja, den Empfang auch. Also das kann ich natürlich boykottieren. Ich kann sagen, also das mache ich natürlich auch regelmäßig. So hey, schicken wir ja keine Word-Dokumente, sondern schicken wir irgendwie keine Ahnung, PDF oder sowas. Da können wir nachher noch ganz viel zu erzählen, was denn irgendwie aus unserer Sicht wirklich eine Alternative ist dazu. Und ja klar, den Empfang kann ich irgendwie boykottieren. Also ich kriege das Fein natürlich trotzdem erstmal, aber schreibe dann auch oft genug den Leuten zurück, so ne, habe ich jetzt keine Lust drauf, nehme ich nicht. Dazu gibt es noch die schöne Angewohnheit von Word-Dokumenten, dass sie auch makrovieren und so ein bisschen enthalten können. Und da habe ich irgendwie gar keine Lust drauf, das will ich gar nicht. Deswegen geht weg.
23 Uhr. Chaos Radio 23 und Standard ist unser Thema.
Ja, Chaosradio 73.
Sag ich doch.
Es geht um Standards. Ihr erreicht uns unter 73 at chaosradio.ccc.de Jo, das ist... Ja, ja, Andreas.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Genau, in der letzten Sendung, falls ihr da was habt. Und da erreicht ihr das Team unter 72 at Chaosradio.
Und jetzt kommt der Clou, Andreas.
Die nächste Sendung. Lass mich raten 74.
Und weiter.
Komm.
Nicht schlecht, ich suche dir mal eben einen Applaus raus hier. Macht schon mal weiter.
Genau, und wenn ihr allgemeine Anfragen habt, die nicht zur Sendung passen, wie zum Beispiel irgendwie ihr habt einen Themenvorschlag oder so, dann schickt es bitte nicht direkt an das Team, an die 73er, sondern an, das hatte ich beim letzten Mal auch schon nicht bewusst, Chaosradio at ccc.de. Unsere normale E-Mail-Adresse für allgemeine Sachen Chaosradio.
Im Zweifelsfall einfach Chaosradio at fritz.de.
Oder auch das funktioniert auch.
Chaosradio at ccc.de, die dürfte eigentlich auch gehen. So Andreas, dieser Applaus ist nur für dich. Ja, keine Ursache.
Ja, Standards. Ich denke, um so ein bisschen die Unterschiede zwischen Standards zu beleuchten, müssen wir mal noch ein paar mehr näher uns angucken, wo sie herkommen, wie sie hingehen. Eben hatten wir Wörthfalls, das ist ein typisches Beispiel für einen Herstellerspezifischen Standard. Das heißt, ein Hersteller sagt, mein Produkt sieht so aus. Die Schrittstelle, die ich dir biete, ist Wörth. Und A4 hatten wir vorhin als ein Beispiel. Das ist halt das Deutsche Institut für Normung, das mal festgelegt hat, dass ein Blatt Papier mit einer Grundfläche von einem Quadratmeter und einem Seitenverhältnis, das dem goldenen Schnitt entspricht, A0 genannt werden soll.
Ach, A0 ist ein Quadratmeter.
A0 ist genau ein Quadratmeter. Mit dem goldenen Schnitt.
Wieder was gelernt.
Die Seitenverhältnisse sind irgendwie 1 zu Wurzel 2 oder sowas, ne?
Wurzel 5, 5 glaube ich. 1 zu Wurzel 5, 5.
Du stellst deinen Gehirn auch nach deinem Tod der Wissenschaft zur Verfügung, oder? Guck mal, was hier alles drin ist.
Ich werde es nach meinem Tod in einen Computer uploaden, hoffe ich.
Oder so, während?
Ja, sozusagen gleichzeitig.
Hast du hier schon Standard für ausgesucht?
Nee, wird es aber vielleicht geben, weil es gibt ja auch Standards für Programme zum Beispiel. Also Java ist so ein Standard, wo der Standard quasi als Firmenstandard angefangen hat. Das hat sich die Firma Sun sich mal ausgedacht, hat beschrieben, so sieht ein Java Programm aus. Diese Bytecode gibt es, diese Standard Libraries muss es geben. Und mittlerweile wird der Java Standard von einem Konsortium verwaltet, das Sun ganz trickreich noch so ein bisschen unter seiner Kontrolle hat. Also sie wollten es nicht an eine Normungsinstitut abgeben, um mehr Kontrolle über den Markt behalten zu können. Also man kann ja mit Standards auch immer Märkte beherrschen beziehungsweise versuchen Mitbewerber aus dem Feld zu drängen. Wenn ein Produkt standardisiert ist, erlaubt es jedem Marktteilnehmern ein Produkt auf den Markt zu bringen und es findet Wettbewerb statt. Jeder kann mit jedem und so weiter und so fort. Und manche Hersteller versuchen das auszunutzen, indem sie erst ein Standardprodukt machen und dann versuchen hier noch ein bisschen was dran zu bauen, da noch ein bisschen was dran zu bauen, dort noch ein bisschen was dran zu bauen. Ihr Produkt attraktiver als die der Konkurrenz machen und nach und nach sich von dem Standard abzulösen, sozusagen die Konsumenten ganz langsam wegzulocken und sie dann einzuschließen und in ihrem eigenen Standard gefangen zu halten.
Erzähl doch mal ein Beispiel.
Microsoft nennt das Embrace und Extend. Also die haben einen Namen für diese Strategie. Und das hat bei Webbrowser ganz gut geklappt. Also vor drei, vier, fünf Jahren war Netscape der Markt für eine Brauser. Heute ist es der Internet Explorer. Und das hat mit genau der Technologie funktioniert.
Ist eigentlich irgendwo dokumentiert, womit Microsoft angefangen hat, ein Standard beim Browser zu verlassen? Also was das erste Feature war, dass da irgendwie...
Na ja, das große Problem ist, es ging... Microsoft hat gar nicht damit angefangen, sondern eigentlich hat Netscape damit angefangen. Ja.
Mensch, jetzt hast du mich aber echt desillusioniert.
Ja, ist wirklich so. Ich glaube, bei Netscape waren es Background Images. Also, die Puristen unter den Webseitengestaltern haben sich am Anfang natürlich über das Blink-Tech aufgeregt. So, wie kann man das nur machen? Da blinkt das da auf der Seite. Das ist ja anstrengend, furchtbar, sieht scheiße aus.
Und es wird immer noch benutzt. Das ist das Irrste.
Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich standardisiert. Also, der HTML-Standard ist ja vom D3C, dem Internetgremium, das Webstandards beschließt. Und das funktioniert in der Praxis so, dass jeder, der da mitmachen möchte, da mitmachen kann. Man muss sich halt dadurch qualifizieren, dass man in der Lage ist, regelmäßig zu diesen Treffen zu fliegen, die überall verteilt auf der Welt stattfinden. Das heißt, man kann da mal hingehen, wenn das in der Stadt stattfindet, wo man ist. Aber wenn man da tatsächlich was bewegen will, muss man halt Geld für Interkontinentalflüge ausgeben. Und dann darf man da mitspielen. Dann treffen sich 30 Leute, die haben da eine Tagesordnung. Und wenn man irgendeinen Einwand hat zu irgendwas, wird einem erzählt, da haben wir schon mal drüber geredet. Da reden wir diesmal nicht drüber. Und das ist ja interessant. Schreibt doch mal bitte was zum nächsten Mal darüber, damit wir eine Beschlussvorlage haben.
Also und so ist es auch zu diesem P3P Standard gekommen, den wir in der letzten Sendung ein bisschen angerissen haben. Der ist ja auch vom W3 Konsortium abgesegnet. Und da hatte ich übrigens das Glück. Genau, das ist nämlich da hatte ich in der letzten vor drei Wochen etwa drei, vier Wochen das Glück, jemanden zu treffen, hat mir nochmal erzählt und hat sich eigentlich auch bestätigt, was wir hier so schon gemutmaßt haben in der Sendung, dass es eigentlich so ein Minimalkonsens ist, dieses P3P. Was macht P3P? P3P war die Plattform for privacy und ist ein Protokoll, ein Datenformat wie Datenschutzrichtlinien auf Firmen, Webseiten beschrieben werden können, sodass mein Browser, mein Client das auslesen kann und mich entsprechend darauf hinweisen kann, dass die Datenschutzbestimmungen der Firma nicht mit denen von meinen übereinstimmen. Und eigentlich unser Ansatz als Chaos Computer Club wäre, dass wir eher sagen, der User gibt vor, was er an Datenschutz eingehalten haben möchte und der Anbieter muss sich dann noch richten. Aber da war einfach kein Konsens für, weil natürlich auch Industrievertreter da sitzen.
Ja, die haben ja auch das Geld für Interkontinentalflüge.
Richtig, genau, das ist so ein bisschen das Manko dabei.
Radio ist ja auch ein Standard. Also so dieses Radiosignal, was da draußen rausgeschickt wird, weil sonst könnte man nicht einfach mit einem beliebigen Radio einen beliebigen Radiosender hören. Und wer standardisiert das Radio?
FM ist nicht standardisiert.
Doch, natürlich.
Ja, das fängt bei 88 MHz an und hört bei 108 auf.
Das sind ja die Frequenzzuweisungspläne vor einer Rekritschung. Das ist auch noch eine schicke Geschichte. Das ist interessant im Zusammenhang mit dem Polizeifunk. Das heißt, es führt zwar eigentlich ein bisschen vom Thema ab, aber das ist immer die große Frage, ob Polizeifunk abhören verboten ist. Und das Problem ist, es scheitert irgendwie da dran, dass eigentlich nirgendswo in diesen Frequenzzuweisungsplänen festgelegt ist, ob das jetzt eine öffentliche oder eine private, eine geschlossene Ausstrahlung ist. Aber das ist nur so am Rande zwischen Frequenzzuteilungsplänen, weil wir da gerade...
Nee, FM ist natürlich standardisiert. Da ist zum Beispiel der Modulationshub standardisiert und die Bandbreite und das Frequenzraster meines Wissens auch und für den Rest gibt es Kanalbelegungspläne. Also ist dann natürlich auch wieder unterschiedlich. Da ist also einiges ist ein technischer Aspekt, so wie funktioniert die Modulation beim Radio. Das mit dem Stereo Signal, also wie weit ist der Stereo, der Träger für das Differenzsignal weg von dem Summenträger, damit man auch den anderen Kanal hören kann. Und manches ist einfach also es geht dann fließend in Gesetzgebung über, quasi wenn es um Frequenzbelegungspläne geht. Auf welche Frequenz darf ich denn jetzt eigentlich Radio machen?
Ja du gar nicht.
Selbstreden darf ich auf 2, 4 Gigahertz mit 10 Milliband darf ich senden, was ich will.
Übrigens gerade bei plus im Angebot glaube ich.
Bei Aldi.
Nee, ist das Aldi? Nee, diese kleinen PMR Walkie Talkies.
Ach die gibt es bei plus?
Gibt es bei plus von 50er, zwei Stück.
Das ist ja cool. Auf 2, 4 Gigahertz?
Nee, das ist LPD, das ist diese 400...
LPD?
430...
Was ist denn das? 70 Zentimeter.
Moment, es ist PMR.
PMR, sind das nicht die 100? Das andere wäre ISM, das ist 2400 Megahertz. PMR ist glaube ich dieses komische 2 Meter Band, kann es sein?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es auch nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall ist bei Plus gesehen die 50 Euro Stück.
Die Funkstrecken, es gibt diese Videoübertragungsstrecken, die sind in dem ISM-Bahn 2, 4 Megahertz.
Genau, kann man an Daten wie zum Beispiel dem 1. Mai und dem 23. Mai in Berlin auch immer erstaunliche Bilder sehen.
Die Hubschrauber der Polizei fliegen über die Stadt und machen Bilder und schicken die eben, weil es gerade funktioniert und preisgünstig und ohne Zulassungsprobleme ist die Sache in einem praktischen ESM-Band runter.
Das ist ja super. Kann ich mir so einen Empfänger selber löten? Oder sind das diese Indoor-Video-Übertragungssysteme für Einfamilien?
Das ist interessant, die Empfänger, die ich kenne, sind umgebaute Analog-Satelliten-Receiver, weil die Tuner sind für die Frequenzen ausgelegt. Da muss man bloß noch sagen, die Frequenz und Videosignale können sie auch verarbeiten. Schön.
Chaosradio 73 und die Standards unser Thema.
Genau.
Danke.
Der PCI-Bus ist zum Beispiel auch so ein...
Entschuldige mal eben Frank. Andreas, würdest du dich dann bitte auch ans Mikrofon begeben?
Pappe. Was? Pappe.
Pappe?
Pappe.
Er braucht seine Visitenkarte wieder.
Pappe. Ich hab Pappe. Okay, wir können weitermachen.
Wir können weitermachen. Guten Abend, hier ist Chaos Radio über 73 auf Ritzel und wir reden heute über Standards.
Und jetzt sind wir eingestiegen.
Wollen wir erstmal was über die DVD erzählen? Also wie ist das eigentlich als Software Standard? Das ist ja überhaupt ein aktuelles Problem und trifft ja auch so ein bisschen direkt unsere Sendung hier. Wenn ich jetzt als Firma sagen würde, ich schreib ein Kalkulationsprogramm, irgendwas, eine Wirtschaftssoftware und ich will mit einem anderen Programm Daten austauschen, dann brauche ich dafür eine Software Schnittstelle. So heißt es. Das heißt also, ich brauche eine Beschreibung davon, wie dieses Datenformat, was der andere lesen kann, aussieht. Also wenn der andere zum Beispiel.doc Word Dokumente irgendwie einlesen will oder Excel Sheets, dann brauche ich eine Beschreibung davon, wie sowas aussieht. Und wenn ich jetzt so mit einem Standard zu tun habe oder mit einem Nicht-Standard, sondern mit einem Dateiformat, die einem Hersteller gehört, der da vielleicht Patente drauf hat und der da irgendwie gar keine Lust drauf hat, dass andere Leute Software machen, die mit ihrer Software kooperieren können, weil sie vielleicht möglicherweise besser sind oder weil sie damit dann in Konkurrenz treten zu einem anderen Produkt, was dann besser ist als ihrem und die Leute plötzlich viel besser mit der Software dann Daten austauschen können als mit ihrer Software, dann ist das für die ein Problem. Und die versuchen natürlich dann diese Beschreibung weitestgehend zurückzuhalten und die Arbeit, die Entwicklungsarbeit von einer anderen Firma möglichst dann hinaus zu zögern. Das ist jetzt mal der böswillige Ansatz dabei. Und dann passiert es auch häufig, dass wenn Firmen Sachen implementieren wollen, also eine Software programmieren wollen, so eine Software-Stelle machen wollen, dass sie dann ein sogenanntes NDA, also ein Non-Disclosure Agreement unterzeichnen müssen. Das heißt also, die kriegen den Standard, die Beschreibung zwar zugeschickt, aber sie dürfen das nur in binärer Form vertreiben. Das heißt, sie dürfen also niemanden darüber Auskunft geben, was sie da gerade gelesen haben. Und dürfen zum Beispiel auch kein Open Source Projekt daraus machen. Das ist ein ganz großes Problem, wo viele Programme, viele Entwicklungsprojekte, die unter der GPL sind, also unter der GNU Public License, das heißt eine freie Lizenz, also die die Öffnung des Source Codes, des Quell Codes erlaubt oder einfach so Open Source sind, die haben da ein richtiges Problem mit, weil die können natürlich sowas nicht unterschreiben, weil es ja genau der Philosophie widerspricht und weil sie eigentlich auch gar nicht anders können, weil sie schon durch andere Programmteile, die sie vielleicht nicht mitbenutzen, an diese offene Lizenz gebunden sind. So und die müssten dann sowas unterschreiben und könnten dann eigentlich gar nichts mehr damit anfangen. Und diese Praktik ist natürlich irgendwie der Tod für Open Source Projekte, die von einer weltweiten Gemeinschaft weiterentwickelt werden können oder wo auch Leute, zum Beispiel Behörden, die werden ja im Moment dazu aufgefordert, auch viele Open Source einzusetzen. Die kommen damit an ihre Grenzen und die Entwickler sind letztendlich die Blöden dabei.
Ja, ein schönes Beispiel, wie Standards benutzt werden von Firmen, um damit Wirtschaftspolitik zu machen, ist auch DVD. Der DVD-Standard ist kein Standard, der jetzt von irgendeinem vom Staat installierten Norman-Institut oder einer ähnlicheren Organisation errichtet wurde, sondern da haben sich Industrievertreter zusammengefunden und sich zusammen an Tisch gesetzt, sich überlegt, wer bräuchte mal was so als CD-Nachfolger und es sollen ganz viele Bits drauf gehen und Filmen soll auch drauf passen und haben sich dann auf was geeinigt. Und das worauf sie sich geeinigt haben, ist immer sehr dadurch geprägt, welche Technologie diese Firmen zur Verfügung haben, welche sie beherrschen, wo sie Patente drauf haben. Also jede der Firmen, die daran beteiligt war, hat zugesehen, dass von ihnen zwei oder drei patentierte Technologien zum Standard erhoben wurden. Das heißt jeder ist gezwungen bei dieser Firma, das Patent zu kaufen, Nutzungsrechte für das Patent zu kaufen. Und sie reden dann immer von ja, fair und competitive views. Das heißt es ist jedem erlaubt, das Patent zu kaufen, zu den gleichen Konditionen. Oh so großzügig sind wir. Und in Wirklichkeit läuft das aber so, dass die großen Firmen, die da in dem Konsortium drin setzen, da die alle Patente da reinwerfen, bilden die gemeinsam miteinander einen Patentpool und räumen sich gegenseitig Nutzungsrechte ein. Haben also effektiv keine Kosten. Aber jeder andere, der dazukommt, der das implementieren will, muss von den allen sich diese Patente lizenzieren. Das heißt, für den wird es wesentlich teurer als für die, die sich damit in den Tisch gesetzt haben. Und es hat auf der einen Seite ein großer Druck für die da mit am Tisch zu sitzen, ihre Standards damit rein zu bringen. Andererseits ist es auch so, dass sie sich manchmal nicht einig werden, dann passieren so Sachen wie bei der beschreibbaren DVD, wo es dann irgendwie DVD-RW und DVD-Plus-RW und DVD-Warm und einige kann man dann in DVD-Playern abspielen und andere nicht. Und bei anderen kann man dann in Laufwerken zumindest die anderen Medien abspielen und es ist ein großes Durcheinander und was letzten Endes natürlich auch die Leute abschreckt, die das kaufen sollen. Und der Grund dahinter ist, man möchte halt mit seiner schon fertigen Entwicklung als Erster im Markt sein. Man möchte, dass eine Patente von allen anderen gekauft werden müssen, man nicht selber die Patente der anderen kaufen muss. Und da wird also auf dem Rücken der Leute, die das hinterher kaufen sollen, schon relativ schmutziger Krieg auch geführt.
Das ist unglaublich, hier lief ein Zettel. Der Blue Moon ist mit telefonieren. Wahnsinn.
Wen sollen wir da anrufen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Was ist das für ein Knopf?
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Hier ist das Chaos Radio 73. Wir sprechen über Standards und wir würden gerne mit euch, liebe Höhrende, über Standards sprechen.
Was haltet ihr denn für den sinnvollen Standard? Also vielleicht gerade auch so bei den technischen Sachen. DIN A4, DIN A5, standardisierte Kondome.
Gibt bestimmt ein Standard für die Größe von Klopapier, oder?
Mit Sicherheit, ja sicher. Ja klar.
Oder?
Die sind eigentlich immer gleich groß.
Normengröße, klar, die müssen ja auch abgezählt werden.
Wobei ich meine, also jetzt können wir...
Die Arschbreite, den Sicherheitsabstand noch.
Die Arschbreite, den Sicherheitsabstand.
Dazu hab ich noch eine gute Anekdote.
Ausflockverhalten.
Genau, die ökologische, die Verträglichkeit.
Ihr kennt doch alle das Space Shuttle Americana. Und das Space Shuttle hat zwei Boosterraketen. Das ist die Boosterraketen vor dir. Weißt du wie der Durchmesser dieser Boosterraketen zustande kommt?
Weiß ich nicht, irgendjemand sagt, wie der ist.
Naja, es gibt da so gewisse praktische Begrenzung. Sie müssen Dinge ja durch die Gegend transportieren, deswegen ist das Ding so breit wie ein Waggon einer Eisenbahn. Und weißt du warum der Eisenbahnwagon seine Breite hat?
Damit der S-Klasse drauf passt?
Nee, das hat mit der Spurbreite der Schiene zu tun. Und die Spurbreite der Schiene hat etwas mit dem Abstand der Räder, der Wägen zu tun und wurde designt nach den Wägen, die da halt in Europa so waren. Und die wiederum wurden halt ursprünglich mal von den Römern angelegt, die irgendwie diese Wägen hatten, wo irgendwie vorne zwei Pferde waren und hinten eine Achse so breit wie zwei Pferde hintern.
Das ist jetzt nicht dein Ernst.
Doch, doch.
Also die Booster Raketen, der Standard für Booster Raketen für Space Shuttle ist zwei Pferde hintern. Das ist verblüffend. Was mich ja ehrlich gesagt viel mehr interessieren würde, ist, welche Standards wirklich totaler Schwachsinn sind. Weil gute Standards hast du ja allenthalben, also so Benzin, 95 Oktan oder 80 oder 90. Hier nochmal die Nummer vom Chaos Radio.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Na dann eben nicht guten Abend. Chaosradio 73 auf Fritz, Standard ist unser Thema und das ist unsere Nummer 1.
Wurzdam 70 97 110 Guten Abend, Jörg.
Hallo.
Ich hab euren Namen gar nicht mitgehört.
Ich als Holger und dann haben wir noch den Frank und den Andreas.
Alles klar. Und zwar, die Sendung hieß ja Standard und dein erster Satz war MS Word und genau das ist auch das, was ich immer so höre. Ja, was haltet ihr und wenn ihr Informatik hattet, was habt ihr? Ja, wir haben MS Excel. Aber dass man erstmal sagt, das ist eine Tabellenkapulation und wir machen halt das Beispiel in Form von MS, aber es gibt da noch Lotus und es gäbe noch Sunsoft, Storges und so weiter, aber es wird halt nur MS gesagt.
Du meinst jetzt so, wenn so Sachen vorgestellt werden oder wenn es darum geht jetzt in der Ausbildung, was gemacht wird, das ist ja auch irgendwie was, was an Schulen ein ganz großes Problem ist. Die armen Kinder, die lernen jetzt halt irgendwie alle Microsoft und die glauben irgendwie, es gibt nichts anderes auf der Welt.
Ja genau, wenn ich ein Computer anmache, dann wird Windows hochgefahren und wenn ich einen Text schreibe, muss ich mal so mit Word machen.
Klar, und die können auch überhaupt gar nicht verstehen, dass irgendjemand auf der Welt irgendwie nicht Word hat, weil er ihnen das Office-Paket nicht gekauft hat.
Das andere.
Jetzt geht das auch schon wieder los. Da muss ich mal kurz unterbrechen, das erinnert mich an diese Szene bei den Blues Brothers, wo die Frau sagt, oh we have both kinds of music, country and western. Also es gibt noch mehr Betriebssysteme außer Windows und Linux und es gibt auch mehr Computer außer PCs.
Aber das ist halt für den PC das momentan zum herankommen. Ich hatte noch was von BSD gehört und hatte BSD mal drauf, aber damit bin ich irgendwie nicht klargekommen.
Was benutzt denn du, wenn du so klassische Office-Anwendungen machen willst unter Linux?
Unter Linux nutze ich das einfache Carbide.
Was hat denn das für ein Speicherformat, weißt du das? Also wenn du das jetzt so eine Datei, die du damit abspeicherst, kannst du die einfach mit einem Texteditor aufmachen oder so? Hast du da schon mal reingeguckt, wie das aussieht? Sind das irgendwie nur wirre Zeichen oder ist da was klares lesbar? Also ich kenne das nicht, aber...
Na ja, dadurch das was ich sehe, sind meistens Quellcodes und die sind halt in der Syntakt von der Sprache.
Ne, ne, also ich meine jetzt mit CarWrite, wenn du da jetzt ein Dokument schreibst und das abspeicherst.
Das hälst irgendwie auch Free. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt das von dem Microsoft-Friedes oder ob das ein anderer Standort ist, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Hälst aber schluck auch Free die Endung.
W-A-I für Writer. Hast du dir OpenOffice schon mal angeguckt?
Ne, das kenne ich doch gar nicht.
Kann ich dir empfehlen.
Im Übrigen, wer jetzt kein hübsches DSL oder eine armdicke Leitung in seiner Wohnung liegen hat, OpenOffice ist auf der Computerbild-Beilagen-CD, also in der aktuellen Computerbild daheim. Und zwar in einer kompletten Version.
Echt schwer zu empfehlen.
Für 1, 50 finde ich das irgendwie... Ja, Computerbild geht eh. Also für...
Finster.
Clickybunti, klar.
Und zwar, ich hätte gleich mal eine richtige, eine Fachfrage, die könnte ich jetzt gleich mal reinstellen. Und zwar, wie hängen LaTeX und PDF zusammen? Weil man hört immer, schicken wir das als, als PDF und so weiter. Und dann sind alle drei Begriffe, PDF, DVI und LaTeX, sind alle eben in dem Zusammenhang zu hören. Und wie ist jetzt, wie sind die Standards entstanden und so? Was ist DVI, was ist LaTeX, was ist PDF?
Also das einzige, was davon tatsächlich ein Standard ist, ist PDF. Ist zwar eigentlich auch bloß ein Firmenstandard, den Adobe mal erfunden hat, aber die haben den halt offen gelegt und viel Software dafür veröffentlicht, sodass der mittlerweile auch von einigen anderen Programmen gesprochen wird. Das ist eine Seitenbeschreibungssprache, wo im Prinzip drin steht. Mach mal links oben einen Buchstaben, dann hübsches Bild daneben und so weiter und so fort.
Ist es ein TeX Standard, also mit diesem Backflash und irgendwelche TeX?
TeX ist kein Standard, sondern TeX ist halt genau ein Programm, also sowas wie Word quasi, nur halt irgendwie, dass es TeX ist. Das hat seine eigene spezifische Inputsprache, das ist dieses TeX. Und das DVI ist im Prinzip ein geräteunabhängiges Ausgabeformat, wo dann drin steht, welches Pixel schwarz und welches weiß ist, aber auch TeX spezifisch, ist auch kein offener Standard.
PDF ist eigentlich einfach gesagt, so was wie Postscript nur für den Bildschirm, für Bildschirmanwendungen hauptsächlich. Postscript ist ja ein Begriff, oder?
Postscript, also ich hab unter Linux, kann man fast alles in Postscript umwandeln. Und da scheint das Dürze ja ein bisschen der zentrale Textformat oder Ausdruckformat zu sein.
Das ist eigentlich eine Seitenbeschreibungssprache für Drucker. Also wurde mal als Standard für Drucker erfunden, damit man nicht für jeden Drucker neu Software programmieren muss, und einfach einen Standardfall dahinschickt. Und das Umsetzen des Postscripts in Pixel machte dann der Drucker früher selber.
Du, ja, okay, wir müssen Nachrichten machen.
Alles klar, ja sorry.
Danke für deinen Anruf. Tschüss. Tschüss, das muss ich nicht entschuldigen. Jakob, Tristan und Katharina, bitte ein bisschen Geduld nach den Nachrichten. Telefonieren wir mit euch. Macht er die Platte kaputt? Das darf nicht wahr sein. Übrigens das Knistern, das mischen wir hier digital drunter, damit es den Eindruck erweckt, als würden wir mit echten Schallplatten arbeiten. Oh, ich kriege gerade eine Nachricht aus der Regie. Wir arbeiten mit echten Schallplatten und der Angler, der legt die auf und zwar live hier im Chaos Radio Fritz.
Dann 101, 5.
Eine nach 12. Heute Nacht Wolkentemperaturen zwischen 15 und 12 Grad, aber trocken. Morgen dann Regen, Regen und nochmals Regen, aber nicht am Nachmittag. Nachmittags kommt die Sonne raus, dann haben wir auch 20 bis 26 Grad. Jetzt die Meldungen mit Kerstin Topp.
Israelische Kampfhubschrauber haben am Abend das Polizeihauptquartier in Hebron beschossen. Einwohner der Stadt berichteten, zwei Hubschrauber hätten Geschosse auf das seit Dienstag von Soldaten belagerte Gebäude abgefeuert. In dem Hauptquartier in der geteilten Stadt im Westjordanland sollen sich etwa 15 von Israels gesuchte Extremisten verschanzt haben. Unionskanzler Kanidat Stoiber hat mehr Leistung und mehr Wettbewerb in Deutschland gefordert. In einer Grundsatzrede im französischen Dom in Berlin plädierte er außerdem dafür, bürokratische Hürden abzubauen. International werde Deutschland inzwischen mit Verkrustung und Unbeweglichkeit gleichgesetzt, sagte Stoiber. Im kanadischen Ferienort Cananeskis hat das Gips betreffend der sieben führenden Industriestaaten und Russlands begonnen. Hauptthema der sogenannten G8-Staaten sind die Hilfen für die ärmsten Länder Afrikas. Auf der Tagesordnung steht außerdem der Kampf gegen den internationalen Terrorismus. Matthias Platzek ist neuer Ministerpräsident von Brandenburg. Der bisherige Potsdamer Oberbürgermeister wurde heute vom Landtag gewählt. Platzek tritt die Nachfolge von Stoiber an, der am Sonnabend überraschend seinen Rücktritt verkündet hatte. Bei der Fußballweltmeisterschaft spielt Deutschland im Finale gegen Brasilien. Die Brasilianer gewannen gegen die Türkei mit 1 zu 0. Das Endspiel wird am Sonntag um 13 Uhr angepfiffen. Und die Verkehrsmeldungen. A13 Dresden Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Groß Chöris und Mittenwalde ist wegen eines Unfalls die Straße gesperrt. Die Polizei regelt den Verkehr. Und A115 Autobahn 3x Funktum, Autobahn 3x Drewitz-Nutetal zwischen Potsdam-Babelsberg und Potsdam-Drewitz. Gefahr durch einen Gegenstand auf der Straße.
Fritz präsentationiert Holzeit und bringt dir die Toten Hosen live in der Wohlheide Berlin. Freitag und Samstag. Und Fritz hat deine Freikarten für die Konzerte von die Toten Hosen.
Chaosradio 73 auf Fritz. Standarts unser Thema, die Musik live aufgelegt vom Angler. Was? Mit Platten.
Platten, Angler.
Vinyl. Was ja irgendwie auch, was ich finde ja immer, ich sag ja immer gerne, ich sag ja immer gerne PVC zu den schwarzen Schallplatten, weil das ja tatsächlich Polyvinylchlorid ist. Nur die Disc Jockeys, die hören das nicht gerne.
Ich sag immer Vinyl, weil es hört so auf so ein schönes Wort auf, das wie Müsli.
0331 7097 110, nur mal falls ihr über Standards reden wollt hier mit uns. Und Jakob der Wilders. Hallo Jakob.
Also ich hab jetzt nicht von Anfang angehört, aber ich denke mal, das hattet ihr jetzt noch nicht. Also einmal ZIP Format, finde ich so ein bisschen, also ist halt auch ein Standard klar und irgendwie überflüssig geworden, meiner Meinung nach. Wurde viel zu oft benutzt. Im Internet, um Dateien zu packen, die vielleicht gerade mal 100 Kb groß sind und man dann ja irgendwie dreifache Mühe hat, die auseinanderzufitzen.
Na ja, wenn sie damit auf 50 K komprimiert werden, wäre es ja in Ordnung. Das Problem ist ja, dass du unheimlich oft irgendeinen ZIP ziehst, was irgendwie ein MB groß ist und entpackst es, dann ist es ein MB und 10 K.
Ja genau, sie selbst entpacken eine Exe drin.
Und enthalten eine Exe drin.
Ja und irgendwie, ich finde ja entweder zwei Dateien an anbieten oder irgendwie, ja weil es haben immer mehr Leute DSL und irgendwie ist es nervig, diese kleinen Dateien.
Ich habe nicht DSL, denn ich wohne mitten in Berlin. Ja in Pellersdorf oder so. Und mitten in Berlin, da ist leider die Telekom nicht willens und in der Lage DSL zu legen, weil ist ja nur die Hauptstadt. Aber das ist doch schön, das wäre was für die ewige Liste oder? Standard, also überflüssige Standards.
Ja, aber ich finde ZIP eigentlich besser als selbst entpackende Exe-Dateien.
Die kann man übrigens auch mit dem GNU ZIP entpacken.
Es gibt aber auch bessere Packprogramme. Also ich weiß nicht, wenn man wirklich was packen will, dann kann man da irgendwie andere nehmen.
Welches zum Beispiel?
Ich finde zum Beispiel Rav besser oder Archer oder so oder Ace oder wie auch immer das heißt. Ja oder also ich weiß nicht, da ist ZIP irgendwie, ja fällt auch immer ein bisschen schlecht dabei ab bei mir.
Was machen die anderen besser?
Kleiner.
Ja die dauern dafür aber auch deutlich länger.
Ja gut, aber wenn man packen will, kommt es ja eigentlich nicht darauf an.
Also genau wie heute hatte ich so ein schönes MP3, also Wave in MP3 Umwandlungsprogramm, da war standardmäßig normal eingestellt.
Race in MP3?
Nee, Wave.
Ach so, Wave.
Die meinten, wenn man hohe Qualität einstellt, dauert es ein bisschen länger, aber bei gleicher Bitrate ist die Qualität eben besser. Aber normalerweise normal eingestellt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so Sinn macht.
Was vielleicht auch irgendwie ein interessanter Irrglaube ist, dass man MP3-Dateien noch mal mit ZIP komprimieren könnte. Das muss man hier mal für die Leute da draußen sagen. Das geht nicht, das bringt nichts.
Aber anderes Format war nicht ein bisschen gemein, war GIF. Das ist ja eine ziemlich schöne Erfindung, finde ich so. Aber neuerdings gibt es wohl nicht mehr auch frei zugänglich. Also ich hab mal versucht mir da für PHP irgendwie Komponenten runterzuladen und da gibt es halt nur noch alte Versionen. Und man kann nicht mehr richtig damit was machen. Irgendwie hatten die begrenzt, also auf Zeit des freigestellt.
Das war ein offener Standard und das haben die zurückgezogen.
GIF oder GIF? Graphic Interchange Format.
Der Standard selbst ist offen, aber das Komprimierungsverfahren, das sie da verwenden, ist patentiert.
Ah, okay.
Bei Komprimierungsverfahren ist ja schon fast eine Frechheit, so was als Komprimierungsencoding machen sie da.
Es gibt halt ein Uralt-Patent von Unisys, das ist eine Firma, die noch nie jemand gehört hat, weil sie glaube ich auch seit 15 Jahren keine Computer mehr bauen, aber irgendjemand hat halt immer noch dieses Patent und besteht da auch drauf, da Gebühren für zu kriegen. Deswegen die ganzen Open Source Programmierer wie die PHP-Programmierer zum Beispiel sehen das in dem überhaupt nicht ein, da irgendwie Lizenzen zu kaufen und bauen. Deswegen schlicht kein GIF-Support mehr ein.
Ja, also da gibt es auch so schöne Umgehungsmechanismen, wo einer irgendwie eine Funktion gefunden hat, wo er dann irgendwie noch die Größe von einem GIF-Bild herziehen konnte und sich daraus irgendwie das ganze System nochmal abgeleitet hat, die Bilder dann noch irgendwie her zu zaubern.
Aber so richtig ist er dann auch nicht mehr.
Nein, also das Entscheidende ist, dass die Programme, die zum Einpacken, also zum Abspeichern von GIF, also die Seite sozusagen, die unterliegt dem Patent, also dafür fallen auch Patentgebühren an. Also die Viewer, wenn ihr zum Beispiel einen Webbrowser, dann müsstest du meines Wissens irgendwie keinen, du willst keine Lizenzgebühr zahlen, weil das einfach nur zum angucken, zum Laden von GIF-Bedern ist.
Ja, angucken geht noch, aber bearbeiten dann schon nicht mehr, oder?
Genau, schreiben da dann wieder was. Genau. Da haben sich die Leute, die das Patent haben, überlegt, ja, wir sorgen dafür, dass man sich es umsonst angucken kann, denn dann haben das alle da draußen und wenn alle das verstehen, ist es der Standard und dann gibt es Bedarf für Werkzeuge, um das zu erstellen. Und da können wir dann fleißig abkassieren.
Aber es war ja wohl auch so, dass es eine Zeit lang sogar unmöglich war. Also es gibt ja diverse Komponenten seit einem Jahr oder so nicht mehr.
Na, das wurde früher nicht verfolgt. Also das Patent bestand schon immer und es war auch schon immer eine Patentverletzung, das zu implementieren.
Ich dachte, das wäre ein kluger Schachzug von denen gewesen, das erst irgendwie auf Zeit erlaubt zu machen.
Na, sie haben es nicht auf Zeit erlaubt, sondern sie haben es halt nicht verfolgt. Das ist, also da weiß man jetzt nicht, ob das Absicht ist oder Zufall. Also das gibt es auch oft, dass sie merken, das ist ja plötzlich populär geworden, da gucken wir mal, wie man damit noch Geld verdienen kann. Das war ja bei mp3 auch so, das haben sie halt mal erfunden, dann lag das rum und dann hat sich das im Internet plötzlich durchgesetzt, weil es verdammt praktisch war, Musikdateien hin und her zu schieben. Dann ist ihnen eingefallen, dass die da ja eigentlich noch Patente drauf haben, dass man da jetzt mal Geld für nehmen könnte.
Das ist auch so wie bei den geringen Mengen, irgendwie bei Haschisch, die sind ja auch nicht legal, nur irgendwie die werden halt nicht straff verfolgt im Moment. Also in den meisten Bundesländern.
In den meisten Bundesländern, ja. Jakob, gute Nacht. Und danke für deinen Anruf. So, weiter geht's auf Damenbesuch. Guten Abend Katawinger.
Hallo. Hallo. Ich hätte mal eine Frage zu den Standards. Und zwar gibt es doch jetzt diese digitalen Signaturen. Und ich wollte fragen, ob es dafür jetzt schon einen Standard gibt?
Also der X509 ist ein Standard, über den man öfter mal stolpert. Das ist ein ISO-Standard, der so im Rahmen dieser ganzen X400, X500 Geschichte entstanden ist. Also als man in Europa davon träumte, so was wie das Internet zu bauen, nur anders. Und wir machen das mal richtig und irgendwie ordentlich und alles schön durchdefiniert. Ah, solltest du mal ühlen. Und da gibt es aber neben X509 auch noch weitere Formate, nämlich PKCS Nummer 11 zum Beispiel. Das ist ein Standard der Firma LSA Incorporated. Und das Signaturgesetz schreibt aber gar keinen spezifischen Standard vor. Das schreibt auch nicht vor, dass man irgendwie einen sich bei einer CA registriert haben muss, die in dem Internet Explorer eingebaut ist, sondern die haben nur sehr allgemeine Umschreibung davon, welche Anforderungen ein solches Signaturverfahren erfüllen soll. Und ob es das dann tut oder nicht, ist eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Aber es gibt noch nichts, was jetzt so richtig durchgesetzt hat.
Wie ist denn das mit GNU-PG, also mit Open-PGP-Signaturen? Würde das irgendwie auch nach dem Signaturgesetz, dem Signaturgesetz entsprechen oder?
Meiner Meinung nach schon. Also X509 ist sehr verbreitet für die ganzen Sicherheitssachen im Web. Also HTTPS zum Beispiel verwendet X.509-Zertifikate. Man kann also ein Dokument damit signieren, kann man im Prinzip auch. Da gibt es auch schon Anwendungen für von Firmen. Aber so richtig im Einsatz ist ja auch dieses Signaturgesetz noch nicht, weil es gibt noch kein Gesetz, wo man laut Signaturgesetz eine Unterschrift dafür braucht. Also es ist ein Gesetz, das sagt, es gibt eine Unterschrift, aber die wird von keinem anderen Gesetz verwendet. Also man kann es einsetzen.
Man kann es probieren. Man ist nicht gezwungen. Ich hab nämlich auch gerade einen Seminarvertrag darüber halten müssen und da hat mich dann fieserweise einer zwischengefragt, ob es da schon einen Standard gibt. Und deshalb wollte ich die Frage mal an euch weiterreichen. Aber es ist sehr erschreckend eigentlich. Es gibt halt ziemlich viele Firmen, die irgendwie was im Internet machen und hin und her schieben und die verwenden das dann gar nicht. Da kann jeder so reingucken und die ganzen Daten.
Ja, das hat aber auch wiederum mit dem Signaturgesetz nichts zu tun, weil das eine Signatur keine Verschlüsselung. Also bei Signatur geht es tatsächlich darum, Rechtsgeschäfte zu tätigen mit Hilfe von Verschlüsselungsmechanismen. Und es hat in vielen Punkten mit dem zu tun, wie man die Verbindung übers Internet sicherer macht. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man auf eine Webseite geht mit HTTPS, dann ist sowohl die Datenübertragung verschlüsselt, als auch über die Signatur ist bestätigt, dass ich wirklich mit dem rede, mit dem ich denke, dass ich rede. Und das erfordert aber noch kein Signaturgesetz.
Aber das Signaturgesetz sagt doch halt nicht nur, dass ich die Unterschrift habe, sondern es sagt halt auch noch, dass ich halt erkennen kann, wenn jemand daran rumgefuscht hat in der Nachricht und so, ne?
Nein, das ist eine technische Anforderung des Signaturgesetzes für Signaturen, die dem entsprechen. Aber Signaturen, auch digitale Signaturen werden auch anderweitig verwendet, als im Signaturgesetz vorgesehen. Ja, so eine Signatur muss halt, elektronische Unterschrift soll halt genau die Eigenschaften aufweisen, dass man hinterher sieht, wenn jemand dran rumgefummelt hat, dass man weiß, wer das ist. Aber in der Praxis sind das alles ungelöste Probleme, weil wenn man ein Trust Center aufbaut, fragt man sich dann wieder, wem kann man vertrauen, der Telekom, oder kann man dem Staat eigentlich wirklich vertrauen für alles?
Oder irgendwelchen Firmen denn ja, Telekom oder VeriSign oder?
Und habt ihr Anwendungen, kennt ihr dann auch gar nicht noch in dem Bereich? Nee? Oder gibt es noch gar nicht so?
Gibt es meines Wissens tatsächlich noch nicht. Was es jetzt gibt im deutschen Recht ist die sogenannte Textform. Das heißt, wofür die Schriftform benötigt wird, ist heute bei einigen Gesetzen die Textform erlaubt. Und das ist jegliche Art von Übertragung von Informationen, die auf der Sichtbarmachung von Zeichen beruht, also auch E-Mail. Man kann jetzt seinem Vermieter eine E-Mail schreiben und das ist rechtsverbindlich.
Ach, ja. Ich hatte nämlich mal was gehört, jetzt im Bereich Bauwiesen, dass man so öffentliche Ausschreibungen schon mit Hilfe digitaler Signaturen vergibt. Und das Ganze auch rechtskräftig ist, weil da gibt es halt noch so eine vom Bau her so eine Norm. So ein Gesetz, das halt dementsprechend geändert wurde und das gibt es halt auch schon zwei Anbieter, die am letzten Zeit explizit dafür halt Werbung machen, dass sie digitale Signaturen verwenden.
Und wer gibt die Signaturen denn aus, weißt du das?
Na, das, also laut Gesetz sind das ja diese Zertifizierungsdienstanbieter und das hört sich ja so an, als wenn das jeder machen kann. Man muss halt nur Bescheid sagen bei Behörde für Telekommunikation und Post. Also die sind auch...
Ja klar, also die Trust Center, die müssen da praktisch lizenziert sein, die müssen eingetragen sein bei der Regulierungsbehörde.
Ja, nee, es ist nicht mal so, dass die, also es gibt da so, es heißt dann, dass das genehmigungsfrei ist, die müssen nur Bescheid sagen, dass sie es machen. Aber wenn sie sich dann, dass das halt akkreditiert wird, dann wird ein zusätzliches Untersuchungen findet statt. Also die sind gar nicht verpflichtet, dass das richtig nachgewiesen ist. Also die sind nur zur Anzeige verpflichtet. Also das ist auch ein bisschen krass, finde ich.
Das ist die Sache mit der qualifizierten Signatur, Andreas? Da gab es irgendwie diese Diskussion, ich kann mich dunkel dran erinnern, ob irgendwie die qualifizierte Signatur gefordert wurde oder nicht.
Ich weiß es auch nicht mehr genau. Also eine qualifizierte Signatur ist immer dann, wenn das Ganze auf so einem Zertifikat beruht. Und sonst heißt es nur einfach elektronische Signatur und da ist gar kein Zertifikat dahinter. Und die Zertifikate werden halt von diesen Zertifizierungsdienstanbietern, so ein schönes deutsches Wort, ausgestellt. Ich hab mich ja mit dem Gesetz beschäftigt und das ist irgendwie alles für mich sehr schwammig, das wieder aussehen, was jeder machen kann.
Das Problem ist auch, dass das größtenteils auch hanebüchener Blödsinn ist, weil sie sich keine Gedanken drüber gemacht haben, was denn jetzt ein Trust Center tatsächlich zertifizieren soll, wer ich genau bin oder was ich mache. Und das hat auch mit diesem X509 Standard zu tun, weil er nicht besonders flexibel ist, es ist nämlich ein streng hierarchischer Standard. Es gibt oben die Root Certificate Authority und dann gibt es darunter dann kleinere Certificate Authorities und dann irgendwann komme ich dann und es geht nur von oben nach unten. Und es gibt andere Ansätze, die nicht so streng hierarchisch aufgebaut sind, also zum Beispiel bei PGP gibt es auch Signaturen für E-Mails und da läuft das über ein Web auf Trust, da gibt es gar keinen Trust Center, sondern da signiere ich den Key von jemanden, den ich persönlich kenne zum Beispiel. Und das ist möglicherweise auch ein sehr viel sinnvollerer Ansatz, von dem offensichtlich nur die Leute im Gesetz nie was gehört haben, wenn sie über Trust Center schreiben. Und auch eine ganz interessante Alternative ist SPKI, es ist Simple Public Key Infrastructure, wird leider auch noch nicht eingesetzt. Also da diese ganze digitale Signaturgeschichte wurde viel gehypt, aber von den derzeitigen technischen Lösungen wird da wenig gehalten.
Das war auch so ein bisschen, was ich so rausgefunden hab. Ich hab immer so im Internet so rumgefragt, wer das schon so verwendet. Und dann kommt man weiß ich was auch auf, das sind mal Seiten vom Bundesgerichtshof und da steht halt drin, die haben so ein ganz tolles Konzept, wann das wie alles umgesetzt werden soll. Aber es gibt halt auch wirklich keinen Bereich, keine Beispiele oder kaum Beispiele zu finden, wo das wirklich tatsächlich Anwendung findet.
Aber ich glaube, der X 509 ist erstmal irgendwie ganz guter Anlaufstelle. Der ist offen oder?
Das ist ein ISO Standard, ja, ja, der ist offen.
Also auch nicht patentbelastet oder?
Nein, man muss sich bloß mit ganz ekeligen Dingen rumschlagen, wie ASN 1 und...
Ich hab nicht die leiseste Ahnung, worüber ihr redet. Salz ist wirklich klasse hier.
Haben wir dir erstmal ein bisschen geholfen?
Ja, das war auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz gut.
Echt, du weißt jetzt mehr als vorher?
Ja, sag mal so, ich weiß jetzt halt, dass es wirklich kaum Anwendungen dafür gibt. Weil vorher dachte ich einfach nur, ich find's nicht. Und jetzt weiß ich halt, dass es wirklich noch so wirklich alles Theorie ist und in der Praxis kaum was passiert.
Okay, das hab ich auch begriffen.
Was in der Praxis tatsächlich gemacht wird, ist, dass Leute sich gegenseitig Mails schicken, womit kryptografischen Mitteln digitale Unterschriften drunter sind. Und das hat halt nichts mit der Rechtsverwirklichkeit des Signaturengesetzes zu tun, weil die auch in einem anderen Planeten leben.
Na vor allem ist ja so, wenn ich so ein Zertifikat ausgestellt bekomme, kostet der mal eben 500 Euro. Ist ja auch nicht grad unbedingt was jeder mal so...
Ja, das steckt auch dahinter, dass manche Firmen da ein dickes Geschäft drin sehen.
Das ist halt eine Dezenz zum Geld drucken, das ist eigentlich.
Ja, Firma Veri-Sign hat sich da auch sehr unbeliebt gemacht.
Katarina, gute Nacht und danke für deinen Anruf. So, Tristan, bist du noch da?
Ja.
Gut, ich glaube Andreas wollte noch was sagen.
Aston 1 ist natürlich auch ein Standard wollte ich noch loswerden.
Natürlich.
Ja, Rastamaß 2, 54 Millimeter ist auch ein Standard.
Rastamaß?
Ja, stimmt, Zehntel Zoll.
Ja, genau, Elektronik. Ich wollte mal sagen, dass es Standards hin und her, also gibt es ja wirklich verdammt viele Beispiele gerade, wenn man so 25 Minuten in der Leitung wartet, die am Einfallen...
Wolltest du dich jetzt beschweren oder wolltest du was sagen?
Ich teile sowieso nicht, ich bin gerade beim Babysitten. Auf jeden Fall wollte ich sagen, dass Standards auch teilweise ganz gut sind, um sie zu brechen, um sich Vorteile der großen Menge gegenüber herauszupicken. Ich denke mal jetzt so an Funkübertragungen, zum Beispiel, wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, die ganzen digitalen Funkübertragungen, um irgendwie Daten hin und her von A nach B mit Richtfunk oder sonst was zu transportieren, sind ja irgendwie auch Standard so in so und so viel Frequenzen und so und so viel Packformaten und weiß-der-geier-was. Und da könnte man eigentlich auch mit ziemlich wenigen Mitteln ein Prinzip machen, wie das eigentlich keiner mehr abhören könnte. Also nicht nur eine digitale Verschlüsselung, die man irgendwie am Computer wieder cracken könnte, sondern zum Beispiel könnte man statt Dual mal Trial senden. Also dass man nicht eins und null sendet, sondern eins, zwei und drei. Und da müsste man sozusagen schon mal löten, um sich irgendwie da ran zu machen, weil die Empfänger...
Ich glaube... Ich glaube, du solltest mal dein Wissen über moderne Empfänger aufbreiten. Also weiß ich, ob du dich damit ein bisschen auskennst. Früher war das so, da hatte man das Superheterodyn Prinzip. Man mischt also auf eine Zwischenfrequenz runter, die fest ist und demoduliert das dann von der Zwischenfrequenz auf das Outputsignal.
Hey, stopp, stopp, stopp! Freunde der Lichtspielkunst, können wir das versuchen so zu machen, dass ich was verstehe?
Nein.
Schade. Na gut, ich bastel mir derweil was, mit der Laubse.
Vielleicht mal ganz kurz der Einwand, du glaubst, weil du einen Standard verwendest, was nicht bekannt ist, was nicht allgemein normiert ist, dass es deswegen keiner abhört.
Ja, man könnte aber auf jeden Fall davon ausgehen, dass es verdammt wenige nur abholen können im Vergleich zu, wenn man mit einem Standardgerät, was man überall kaufen kann, halt darüber sein digitales Signal versendet.
Okay, aber du stellst dir gerade diesen Superempfänger vor. Stell dir mal vor, der Demodulationsteil würde fehlen und du würdest direkt die Zwischenfrequenz wegsamplen. Dann kannst du das hinterher in Software demodulieren. Und da muss man nicht mehr viel löten.
Ja gut, dann lass uns meinetwegen AMFM-Mix machen oder noch eine andere Modulation.
Das ist alles kein Problem. Das sind 5 Zeilen Code in diesem System. Da gibt es im Netz Screenshots von den Überwachungssystemen, die die anständigen Dienste so verwenden. Und da kann man einfach komplette Modulationsverfahren und Protokolle nachladen. Also da gibt es so einen dicken Stream, da kann man klicken mit Plusen davor, wie man das kennt, von seinem Windows. Wenn man mal im Explorer durch die Platte sich durchklickt, sieht man einen 34 Megawit Stream, klickt man irgendwie drauf, sieht dann aha, es handelt sich um eine SDH Verbindung, da sind ATM Pakete drin, da gucken wir mal, da ist der PVC, ach da ist der IP Pakete, über die IP Pakete läuft gerade eine Mail, in dem Mail ist ein Attachment. So durchklicken, von vorn von der Signalanalyse bis hinten zur Auswertung des Content Formats in einer Oberfläche. Und das kostet die echt ungefähr eine halbe Stunde, mal kurz dein neues Modulationsverfahren einzubauen. Und dadurch, dass man sich nicht an die Standards hält, erreicht man keine Sicherheit.
Und PVC habe ich verstanden.
Ich auch.
Aber wahrscheinlich falsch.
Haben wir dir die Illusion genommen, oder?
Ja, wunderbar. Dann wünsche ich euch noch eine schöne Sendung. Und noch eine Frage habe ich und zwar, bin ich gerade am Anfang mir ein Computer anzuschaffen, und so und alles, und habe vor so CNC und Schriftmotoransteuerung ein bisschen zu praktizieren.
Kauft ihr was ganz Altes vom Trödelmarkt mit vielen ISA-Steckplätzen? Nee, es ist wirklich wahr, weil diese ganzen...
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß. Also ich habe auch einen 486er jetzt, und ich werde mir noch von einem Kumpel, der hat mir einen neulichen Computer gekauft, der ist zwar in Mainz, aber den muss man irgendwie holen. Und ich wollte halt fragen, ob irgendjemand irgendwie auch vielleicht Schaltpläne für einfache Treiber hat, also Hardware.
Guck mal im Netz, da gibt es ganz viel. Schriftmotorsteuerung und so ein Kram, das findest du auch mass. Also muss halt selber lüten, ne? Also ist nicht zum Kaufmann bestellen. Aber selbst das geht auch. Geh mal irgendwie nach Treptower auf dem Trödelmarkt oder so, da findest du garantiert ein altes Mainboard mit ganz vielen ISA-Plätzen für 5 Euro. Also schönen Abend noch.
Danke gleichfalls, Tristan. Danke für deinen Anruf, tschüss. Das ist das Chaosradio 73 hier und standards unser Thema. Das hier ist die Nummer zum Mitreden.
1-1-0.
Und wir lehnen uns jetzt mal ein paar Minuten zurück. Eine Minute nach Mitternacht. Das ist Chaos Radio 73. Chaosradio 73 auf Fritz, Standards unser Thema. Die Musik kommt vom Angler.
Wie war die Webseite, Frank?
www.antennenkind.
Antennenkinder. www.antennenkinder.de Und nicht nur wir reden über Standards, sondern wir wollen auch mit euch über Standards reden, liebe Höhrenden.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Name Florian. Schließt einfach los.
Ja, ich bin schon dabei. Es ging ja so um Standards. Und jetzt wollte ich mal so ein bisschen dazu tönen, wie man anderen Leuten ein bisschen Ärger ersparen kann, wenn man sich an selbige Standards hält. Denn Beispiel, die meisten unserer Frequenzzuteilung sind ja international standardisiert. Ich denke jetzt so zum Beispiel Kurzwellenradio, Frequenzen oder auch Fernsehen glücklicherweise. Nur gibt es so in manchen Ländern Europas noch die Angewohnheit, ja Fernsehkanalfrequenzen sind ein bisschen wenig. Also hängen wir da noch ein paar Sonderkanäle zwischendrin rein. Zum Beispiel. Und ist ja alles kein Problem, weil geht ja alles nur übers Kabelnetz. Und auch da sind Standards vorgeschrieben, wie zum Beispiel Schirmungsmaß.
Was ist das?
Es gibt zum Beispiel aus diesem Fernsehverteilkabel nur ein bestimmter Anteil des Signals durch die Isolation und die Abstromung nach außen dringen darf.
Verstehe.
Ja und unser größter deutscher Kabelnetzbetreiber, also die Firma mit dem rosa T, die hält sich auch wunderbar dran. Nur dummerweise fängt das Problem in den Haushalten an der Telefon, nicht an der Telefon, sondern an der Kabelnetzdose an, wo dann die Mieter ihre Kabel, die wildesten Kabelkonstruktionen ranhängen. Und dummerweise als Funkamateur weiß ich das, sind einige dieser Sonderkanäle in einem Frequenzbereich gelegen, der für Fernsehen eigentlich gar nicht freigegeben ist. Also nur halt maßgabe drab gebunden und so. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel hier mein 2 Meter Amateur Funk Gerät anmache und auf die Frequenz von 145, 75 MHz einstelle, liegt im 2 Meter Amateur Funk Bereich dem Amateur Funk primär exklusiv zugewiesen.
Ja, da wird übrigens noch mehr auf uns zukommen. Also du hast jetzt von Kabelnetzen gesprochen, ne? Weil es ist ja so, wenn die Kabelnetze dann mal irgendwie alle verkauft sind, dann gibt es die Netzebene 3 und 4 Betreiber. Das sind also die, denen praktisch die letzte Meile, also das, was bei dir zu dir ins Wohnzimmer geht, denen hört es dann und die machen dann, was sie wollen. Also die haben dann einfach ein Kabel bei dir in die Wohnung. So und die machen dann zwar irgendwie Fernsehen auf den Kanälen, aber sie werden auch noch Internet machen und dies und jenes und knallerer. Und dann wird dieser ganze Frequenzbereich von ja im Prinzip 0 bis 862 MHz belegt. Und da wirst du als Amateurfunker noch ganz viel Spaß haben bei den Frequenzen, die dir dazu kommen.
Ja, das sehe ich auch schon bei Powerline, also Internet übers Stromkabel.
Das wird doch eh nix.
Ja, es wird eh nix.
Nee, es wird wirklich wahr. Ich habe mal bei einem Netzbetreiber das Spektrogramm gesehen. Also das, was in diesem Frequenzbereich an Störungen von den Haushalten kommt, ins Kabelnetz reinstört, auf den Frequenz, wo diese Powerline sein soll. Und da war für mich irgendwie vom Sehen allein klar, das wird nix, die haben da zu viel Störungen. Also wenn jemand irgendwie eine Bohrmaschine anmacht, dann hat das Haus kein Internet mehr und so eine Sache. Das wird nix.
Das sind nicht nur die Bohrmaschinen und so andere handliche Haushaltsgeräte, das sind auch unsere leistungsstarken Rundfunksender auf Kurzwelle. Denn das bewegt sich ja alles im Frequenzbereich bis 30 MHz, soweit ich weiß. Und wenn da so Radio USA mit mehreren Megawatt sendet, dann wird es da sowieso nix. Zumal ja auch wir in Europa und sonstwo auf der Welt keine abgeschombten Netzkabel haben.
Obwohl manchmal haben diese schlechten Kabel, die die Leute installieren, auch gewisse Vorteile. Also es gibt einige Leute, die auf ihrer Zimmerantenne Premiere empfangen.
Ja, das ist schon ein Vorteil für einige Leute.
Ja, wenn der Nachbar halt irgendwie Premiere hat und ein billiges Kabel dran hat, kann man halt mitgucken.
Ja und meine Nachbarn freuen sich, wenn ich auf zwei Meter Betrieb mache, weil sie an Kabel eins nichts mehr hören. Außer nicht.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Kannst ja noch versuchen, die Filme falsch zu synchronisieren, die da laufen.
Ja, da müsste ich ja nebenbei noch Fernseh gucken. Das geht ja dann nicht.
Das ist allerdings richtig. Florian, danke für deinen Anruf. Und gute Nacht.
Euch auch.
Danke. 0331 77 97 1 1 0 ist die Nummer, unter der wir uns erreichen können. Hier in Blumenau, Fritz im Chaosradio. Und angerufen hat, äh, André. Ja. Ja.
Richtig.
Auch gut gemerkt. Hallo.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich mal sagen, was gut geklappt hat, finde ich.
An Standards jetzt.
An Standards ist GSM. Also da hätte man sich vorstellen können, was da für eine, für eine Sache passieren können, wenn man, wenn diese Sache nicht so gut gelaufen wäre. Also man kann ja im Prinzip in jedes Urlaubsland fahren.
Außer Amerika?
Gut, da bräuchte man ein Dreiband. Das soll ja auch nicht das Problem sein, oder? Und ich glaube, in den asiatischen Ländern, glaube ich, da muss man auch noch ein Austauschhändler nehmen. Aber ich meine, das ist eine für sich eine Sache, die ich, die ich fantastisch finde. Also, dass man wirklich in jedes Land fahren kann, wenn man schaltet ein Handy ein, mindestens europaweit, also Spanien auch und Frankreich etc. Das finde ich fantastisch.
Das stimmt. Also der GSM Stand, da haben sie wirklich mal was Gutes hingelegt. Wenn auch ein bisschen verunglückt ist, sind die Verschlüsselungsstandards, die da vorgesehen sind, wobei also nicht direkt der Standard. Andreas, wie war das nochmal? Da gab es was mit dem?
Ja, die haben da ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Also es gibt auch am Standardsachen, die so ein bisschen zweifelhaft sind, wo man das Gefühl hat, da hat noch mal jemand nachgeholfen, damit es nicht ganz so sicher ist, wie es sein könnte. Also die Schlüssellänge für die Verschlüsselung wird zum Beispiel künstlich verkürzt um 10 Bits laut Standard. Und es ist auch nicht sichergestellt, dass das Netz, bei dem man sich einbucht, wirklich das Netz des Betreibers ist. Deswegen funktioniert auch nur dieser Inseacatcher. Das Telefon beweist dem Netz, dass das Telefon das Telefon ist. In Verschlüsselung des Algorithms. Umgekehrt passiert das nicht. Aber ansonsten ist GSM eigentlich ziemlich gut gelungen. In 80ern haben sie alle drüber gelästert und haben GSM als Great Software Monster bezeichnet, weil es ein unheimlich komplexer Standard war. Aber es hat sich gezeigt, die Computer sind schneller geworden. Auch das, was in den Telefonen an Rechenlassen zur Verfügung steht, ist wesentlich mehr geworden und es ist heute gar nicht so ein Problem, wie damals viele befürchtet haben.
Also ich glaube, da stürzen die Telefone heute dafür mehr ab, als mit dem GSM das Problem ergibt.
Ja, ja, also das ist kein Protokollproblem, sondern wirklich dann ein Endgeräteproblem.
Was ich noch fantastisch finde, ist DECT für die Hausanlage.
Die schnurlosen Telefone jetzt.
Die schnurlosen Telefone. Was ich allerdings in dem Zusammenhang ganz witzig finde, diese Frequenz ist ja soweit ich weiß in Amerika vom Militär besetzt. Und ich kann mich da an zahlreiche Shows erinnern mit Jay Leno, mit seiner Tonight Show, wie er sich super aufregt, dass er nicht mal oft dafür ran damit seinem schnurlosen Telefon telefonieren kann. Ja, also die Ränder mit in Amerika glaube ich ist immer noch so, dass da keine Handys verkauft werden können, wo man keine Antennen rausziehen kann. Weil ich glaube die Amerikaner sind immer noch so drauf, dass ohne Antennen kann es nicht funktionieren.
Die haben noch ihre alten analogen Telefone. Bei DECT fällt mir ein, dieser Standard ist glaube ich nicht wirklich offener. Ich könnte jetzt nicht einfach hingehen und sagen, ich lad mir diesen Standard runter und baue mir denn so ein Telefon nach. Zumindest gibt es aber Teile oder der Teil, der die Verschlüsselung regelt. Der ist für mich nicht einsehbar. Das würde ich ja als Kritikpunkt sehen bei DECT. Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen meinen Weg erforschen will, wie diese Verschlüsselung funktioniert, ob sie überhaupt funktioniert, wenn ich wissen will, ob sie überhaupt eingeschaltet ist bei den Geräten, dann muss ich da irgendwie spezielle Anforderungen erfüllen und im Zweifelsfall auch einfach viel Geld auf den Tisch legen, um diesen Standard lesen zu können. Na ja, schon, weil natürlich niemand feststellen kann, ob diese Verschlüsselung wirklich so gut ist, wie sie ist. Also das ist dann diese öffentliche Einsicht, den Quellcode, den wir eigentlich auch immer fordern, der ist nur dann gegeben, wenn dieser Quellcode auch wirklich öffentlich ist und die Leute dann später auch darüber berichten können, was sie in diesem Quellcode gelesen haben oder eben den Quellcode an den entsprechenden Stellen rausgeben können, Stellen markieren können. Und das dürfen sie eben nicht, wenn sie dafür so ein Stillschweige-Agreement unterschreiben müssen.
Wie sieht es da eigentlich momentan mit den Privatleuten aus? Ist es immer noch sicher gegenüber Privatleuten, dass das deckt? Dass sie da nicht mit irgendwelchen super neuen Funkscannern vorbeifahren können und mithören können?
Na ja, das ist halt genau der Punkt, das weiß man nicht so genau. Es gibt immer mal wieder Gerüchte darüber, dass es tatsächlich deckt in Anführungszeichen Messempfänger gibt. Aber es ist weder bestätigt noch es das widerlegt, weil genau einfach dieser Teil des Standards nicht einsehbar ist. Es ist kein ausreichend offenes Standard.
Wir können halt nicht mal sagen, ob es irgendwie wahrscheinlich ist, dass so eine Geräte existieren, weil vielleicht stellt irgendjemand fest, der sich ein Standard anguckt, höhö, lacht einmal, da haben sie aber Mist gebaut, dann baut er irgendwie ein paar Minuten so ein Gerät. Oder es kann auch wirklich sein, dass es echt kompliziert ist, dieses Zeug abzuhören.
Ich dachte, da gibt es jetzt schon zumindest für offizielle Stellen sichere Möglichkeiten.
Wir können doch einfach dein Telefon abhören, also dein Anschluss ist viel einfacher. Können Sie vom Büro aus machen, klicken, brauchen Sie nicht mal losfahren.
Ja gut, okay, so kann man sich auch sehen. Vielleicht, wenn wir noch einen Moment Zeit haben, wollte ich noch was sagen zum Sitzformat. Und zwar, wenn es noch, weil wir das Thema hatten von einem Anrufer, und zwar gehöre ich zu denjenigen, die noch den Norden Commander kennen. Also ich bin es gewohnt, ich sag mal so direkt mit der Nase auf der Festplatte rumzuschrammen, also dass ich die Dateien vor mir sehe, dass ich löschen kann. Also ich meine jetzt natürlich löschen, in dem Sinne, dass ich genau sehe, was auf der Festplatte ist. Und und nicht über solche Sachen wie den, wie heißt das bei Microsoft Explorer, glaube ich, oder Teil Explorer, Datei Explorer, sage ich jetzt mal dazu. Windows Explorer. Genau, ich glaube, die Microsoft-Jünger, die jetzt dazu kommen, ich glaube, die kennen das nur noch so mit diesen, mit den Icons und so weiter und so fort und unübersichtlich. Und ich finde das grauenhaft so was. Also ich brauche, ich brauche ein Programm, wie den mit dem Norden Commander. Gut, den gibt es natürlich jetzt in dem Sinne nicht mehr, der wurde nicht mehr weiterentwickelt. Und dann nehme ich jetzt einfach den Windows Commander, ist ein Klon und sieht an und für sich fast genauso aus.
Unter Linux gibt es auch den Midnight Commander und ich glaube noch 26 andere Klonus.
Wie ist das mit dem ZIP, du wolltest ja zu was sagen.
Ja und zwar hat es Vorbereitung. Bei dem Programm ist es so, dass man sich ein ZIP Programm, WinAce Programm oder mit brah gesippte Sachen auf den Rechner und dann macht man einfach einen Doppelklick drauf und sieht was drin ist. Dann markiere ich die Teilen die ich haben möchte und sage kopieren, dann wird es also von links nach rechts kopiert und ich sage das jetzt mal so Windows Commander mäßig. Und das war's. Also ich brauch da kein WinZIP, kein WinAce, nur in Ausnahmefällen. Ich dachte dann ja ich schaff das nicht oder so und dann muss ich halt doch mal dieses Programm anstatten. Ich hab nicht das Problem wie der Anrufer mit dem Programm, die jetzt halt von 1 Mega oder so auf 800 Kilo runter gesippt sind. Das geht rucki, das ist okay.
André, danke für deinen Anruf. Und weiter mit Björn.
Ich ruf bei euch an, weil ich möchte ja eine Betriebssysteme auf RWs raufpacken und dann möchte ich meine Kiste damit booten.
Coole Sache.
Ja, dachte ich.
Und auf alle Fälle, naja, ich bin mal im Suchen und so, aber nicht am Finden.
Was für ein Betriebssystem willst du denn darauf machen?
Na ja, ich dachte erst mal an die ganzen Microsoft-Dinger. So und auf alle Fälle dachte ich, dass ich das Programm finde, was denn auch diese UDF-Farbenmarkt in dem geschrieben wird, was auswerten kann, damit ich dann die Kiste hochkriege.
Und da Windows wäre dann kein Problem.
Ja, die könnt ihr dann lesen. So und da dachte ich, ich rufe an und frage mal, ob ihr vielleicht so ein Programm kennt. Ey, das ist aber wirklich, ne?
Also ich kann dir sagen, wie du das zum Beispiel mit Linux machen kannst.
Oh, ja komm.
Na, also da trägst du einfach ein Loopback Device anzulegen, also ein virtuelles Fallsystem als Datei auf die CD zu packen.
Also das halte ich jetzt nicht an, sie schneit, aber...
Ich auch nicht, mach hier nichts draus.
Aber vielleicht liegt es daran, dass ich mich noch super wenig mit Linux...
Nimm dir einfach mal zum Beispiel die Suse-CD und guck dir an, wie die das gemacht haben.
Also du meinst, die Tablet-CD eigentlich direkt zu erstellen?
Ja, eigentlich ohne gute Idee.
Noch besser eigentlich.
Auf jeden Fall besser als Windows.
Und dann hab ich noch eine Frage. Und zwar betrifft das Hardware direkt so. Also was passiert denn, wenn ich zwei Boards habe, sagen wir mal zwei ältere, und ich will die zusammenschließen, aber ohne Netzwerkkarte und so weiter, von wegen ihrer Q-Knappheit und wie ist der Geier. Und ich nehm da einfach ein Flachbandkabel und steppselt da drüber. Ich meine, ich möchte die Boards nicht verlieren.
Du musst auf jeden Fall noch einen Spoiler anbauen. So ein Plastikteil. Nee, Infrarot vielleicht?
Aber wie sieht es aus mit den BIOS? Wie wird das denn erkannt werden? Habt ihr da vielleicht einen Plan? Also ich meine, wenn ich eine Festplatte ranstecke, dann scannt die BIOS das Ding ab, und ein bisschen hinterher, ah, das ist von der und der Firma, blablabla, die Daten, die Zylinder und die Köpfe, ja und alles klar. Aber wenn ich jetzt einen direkten anderen Controller ranstecke, wirst du dann, naja, dann habe ich Bedenken, dass die sich irgendwie verstehen.
Also wenn es GASI ist und du die Device ID des Controllers ändern kannst, na, mit IDE geht es nicht.
Und wenn man da irgendwie was zwischen stecken würde, so einen kleinen Adapter, der eigentlich nur die Bedenken miteinander kommunizieren lässt, also ein Adapter für jeden, die bei dir vorgaukelt, wirst du.
Das würde im Prinzip gehen, erfordert einem ein bisschen Aufwand. Da musst du nicht einfach nur das Kabel vertauschen, sondern musst du einen Micro-Controller nehmen und auf beiden Seiten das IDE-Protokoll sprechen.
Das würde eigentlich ausreichen, weil der ein ziemlich primitive Format ist eigentlich, oder?
Ist dann aber auch nicht so besonders schnell.
Naja, da müsste man richtig in der Gierin stecken, um das richtig...
Das ist noch einfach ein Parallelportkabel. Parallelportkabel.
Ja, wisst ihr, ich hab mich jetzt berechnet, und ich hab die jetzt mit einem Serienkabel verbunden und das läuft echt kacke, und ey, man sieht mir so ein Power-Up vom Rechner, ey, dass das wirklich erschreckend ist.
Immer ein Parallelportkabel, das geht viel, viel schneller, weil die Sachen, wie die Namen schon sagen, parallel rübergehen. Probier das mal.
Ey, ey, das war's eigentlich schon.
Wir sollten vielleicht nochmal unser Thema sagen heute im Chaosradio 73.
Es geht um Standards, Standards in allen Varianten. Zip-Standard, Word-Dokumente, Flash, PDF, DIN A4, Kondomlängen.
Standardfinger für Telefonzellen. Und Stützstrümpfe. Ja, und wenn ihr darüber mit uns reden wollt, dann könnt ihr das gerne tun, wenn ich die... Also 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. Name Holger. Klasse Name.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen.
Ja, guten Morgen. Möchtest du mit uns über Standards sprechen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage über Standards. Was auch Musik betrifft und eine Radiostation, was kennst du da vielleicht besser aus? Es gibt ja das Dolby Surround seit ein paar Jahren. Und das sind also das Quadro viele Surround, diese vier Boxen dabei, Kino-Ton zum Beispiel. Und ja, es gibt viele alte Aufnahmen. Die meisten sind noch in Stereo. Mich würde interessieren, inwieweit die bei euch Aufnahmen dieser Art gespielt werden oder das von Standard ist. Also ich hab an Computer-Dateien, MP3-Dateien, die sind ja alle noch Stereo. Inwieweit das verbratet ist oder Aufnahmen gemacht werden oder in Tonstudios gemacht wird.
Na, auf DVDs gibt es auf jeden Fall den 5 plus 1 Standard. Und ich glaube, es gibt sogar auch Fernsehsender, die das digital ausstrahlen.
Wobei ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen weiter ausholen, weil da stecken irgendwie, glaube ich, drei oder vier Aspekte drin, die man beleuchten müsste. Dolby Surround ist erst mal...
Surround ist nicht leicht Surround.
Ja, ja, das ist nämlich nicht dasselbe. Es sind nicht immer vier eigene Kanäle. Na, das ist egal, ob das Filme oder Musik ist. Das handelt sich dabei um Ton. Entscheidend ist, dass manchmal halt nur zwei Kanäle aufgezeichnet werden und die anderen Boxen, die dazukommen, die werden dann rechnerisch damit reingemischt, das heißt, es ist sozusagen kompatibel zu Stereo. Man kann es auf eine Stereo Kassette aufnehmen, man kann es übers Radio übertragen. Und wenn man so einen Surround-Decoder hat, kann man das dann trotzdem auf vier Boxen hören. Und es gibt Verfahren, wo man tatsächlich mehrere Kanäle hat, die einzeln gespeichert werden, wie das auf DVDs neuerdings üblich ist.
Oder gibt es auch diesen Dolly Surround codiert, eventuell als Radiostream oder sowas?
Das ist bei manchen Alben drin, das ist eher selten. Es gibt zwei, drei Künstler, die haben da mal rumgespielt, ist sehr, sehr unüblich, aber es würde funktionieren. Also wenn hier in dieser Musikdatenbank, die ich nicht kenne, irgendwo ein Stück ist, wo der Künstler das angelegt hat mit Surround Sound, dann kannst du das mit einem Surround Sound Decoder hören, wenn es hier läuft.
Kommt es auch über das Radio? Geht es an das analoge Radio, von den Frequenzen her, von den Federn, die da sind?
Ja, ja, was sie tun, ist, dass sie die rückwärtigen Kanäle dadurch errechnen, dass sie irgendwie das Sonnensignal und das eine invertiert und mit einem 3db abgesenkt und dann daraus errechnen sie diese Pseudo-Kanäle. Also man hat nicht wirklich vier Kanäle zur Verfügung, sondern man hat bloß so einen Raumeffekt.
Funktioniert das dann immer noch trotz der Kompressoren? Also bevor ein Signal hier rausgeht, da sind ja Kompressoren und Soundprozesse.
Sobald es jetzt auch nicht so spannend ist, wenn wir hier im Studio stehen und du dann Surround Sound hast, weil wir jetzt eh alle vor dem Mikro stehen. Und du könntest vielleicht noch erahnen, wie wir jetzt hier im Raum aufgestellt sind.
Ich denke, es gibt da mehrere Probleme. Also ein Problem ist, dass es hier ja aus so einem System kommt, wo sowieso bloß noch MPEGs liegen und schon die MPEG-Kompression. Waff? Dann ist da kein Problem, aber es kann schon sein, dass die Kompressoren dann noch das etwas verleiden, den Spaß daran.
Beim Thema Dolby, also das 5 plus 1-Verfahren, fällt mir auch nur wieder deren Lizenzpolitik ein, die nicht gerade freundlich ist.
Oh ja, Dolby ist eine Schweinefirma. Die wollen pro Audio-Kanal, den man in seinem Empfänger drin hat, einen Dollar dafür, dass sie diesen Standard definiert haben, weil es ist ja kein Industriestandard, sondern ein Firmenstandard von der Firma Dolby. Und die haben es auch geschafft, durch Lobbying ihren Dolby-Standard in DVDs reinzukriegen. Und sogar ProSieben strahlt über Digitalradio mit Dolby-Surround-Ton aus, mit 5.1. Übrigens der Tipp, also Filme gibt es tatsächlich und zwar, ich glaube, bei den deutschen Sendern tatsächlich nur bei ProSieben in Surround-Ton kann man sich fünf Boxen kaufen, um sich rum aufzustellen, braucht man bloß eine Digitalschüssel für.
Gibt es in Tonstudios, ist das schon Standardaufnahme, Abmischung damit?
Das solltest du dem Tontechniker fragen, aber ich würde nicht davon ausgehen.
Also hier nicht offensichtlich?
Nein, hier ganz bestimmt nicht. Also das würde überhaupt keinen Zweck erfüllen, wenn wir hier im Dolby Surround ein Signal ausgeben würden. Also es würde nur kosten und nicht nutzen.
Aber es würde sicherlich zur Atmosphäre dieser Sendung beitragen, wenn man hören würde, wo das Rascheln herkommt im Hintergrund. Du weißt schon, dieses.
Okay, das hätte was Cooles sicher, aber. Wir sind froh, wenn wir Stereo senden. Holger.
Ja.
Gute Nacht. Und Hallo Christian.
Ja, hallo, guten Morgen. Ich habe, bin ich jetzt online?
Nein, du bist on air. Unser eins, unser eins. Das ist on air.
Also das erste war mein Favoritstandard, das ist übrigens XML mit, der ist gut.
Da hab ich ja immer noch gar nicht begriffen, was das überhaupt ist, ne?
Nein, ne, das stimmt nicht ganz.
Doch, das stimmt, ich hab das nicht begriffen.
Ja, okay, aber meine erste Frage war eigentlich zum Thema IPv6, wurde noch nicht genannt. Ist ja nun eigentlich auch schon so ein Standard, richtig? Ich meine, gibt's ja schon eine Weile.
Ja, das Thema haben wir eigentlich völlig übersprungen leider, also wir wollten ja eigentlich auch ganz viel über die ITF erzählen. Darum hätte es ja sein können. Ist das IPv6 oder auch v4 oder überhaupt IP?
Nein, meine Frage war ja auch vielmehr zur IPv6, wann das jetzt eigentlich zum aktiven Standard wird, weil...
Es ist bereits.
Sie bitte?
Na gut, aber es wird immer noch nicht benutzt von T-Bekommunikation.
Nur weil es bei Windows nicht zum Klicken geht, heißt es ja nicht, dass es...
Es geht bei Windows zum Klicken, die IPs gehen es nicht an.
Es wird aber noch nicht... Na wie sagt man das? Na benutzt von den ISPs, also angeboten, wenn ich eine Standleiterin serviere.
Wie bitte? Dann hast du den falschen ISP.
Wer bietet das denn an?
Na, das würde mich jetzt auch interessieren.
Da haben wir wieder einen Hund voll genommen hier, ne?
Also ich weiß, dass es auch in Deutschland eine 6-Bone dafür gibt, aber...
Man kriegt das raus, wer so was anbietet, indem man beim Raibe einfach nachguckt, wer größere Mengen IPv6-Namensraum vergeben hat. Könnten wir ja auch gar nicht.
Das Problem bei IPv6 ist ja eigentlich, dass auch die ganzen Webseiten, also es wird ja eigentlich erst dann aus meiner Sicht zumindest zum quasi Standard, wenn, also zum benutzten Standard, wenn auch die ganzen Windows-Leute das auch benutzen, also Webseite aufrufen und stellen halt, dass der Name in die IPv6-Adresse umgewandelt wird anstatt in die V4. Weil derzeit noch nicht.
Ja, naja, das...
Und jetzt ist meine Frage, ob das nun eher an Windows oder halt eher an Telekom zum Beispiel in Deutschland liegt oder wer da jetzt so nachziehen muss.
Also das ist ein Henne-Ip-Problem, ganz klar.
Wahrscheinlich, die ISPs bieten es nicht an, weil es nicht nachgefragt wird und weil die ISPs kein IPv6 anbieten, hat auch keiner Bedarf seine Server umzustellen. Also ich denke bei den Webseiten wird das relativ schnell gehen. Die haben im Prinzip alle schon IPv6.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, was die Endusern machen.
Ja, bei den Endusern funktioniert es auch. Die müssen eh nicht updaten, es geht. Man muss einfach bloß einen ISP finden, der IPv6 auf seiner Modemleitung oder seinem DSL liefert und dann geht das alles. Funktioniert prima.
Das Problem ist, mir fallen dazu auch keine Begriffe ein, wovon ich da im Google suchen kann oder sonst wo. Wo halt dann halt so gesagt wird, ab wann das so ist. Ich hab neulich auch mal jemand gefragt, auf so einem Tag auf einem Thema im ISP und die haben gemeint, ja, also so.
Wenn der Markt es nachfragt.
Datum sagen.
Wenn der Markt es nachfragt, werden sie sagen.
Oder wenn die Bude endgültig voll ist.
Es gibt ja nicht die Internet-Welt-Regierung, die beschließt, dass ab 1.1.2003 nur noch IPv6 zu verwenden ist.
Nee, das ist schon klar, aber ich hab auch neulich...
Ich dachte N-Quadrat würde...
Also schon ne Weile her kam auch mal die Nachricht, übrigens auf Fritz ziemlich spät, dass jetzt halt der Adressraum knapp wird und dass man möglich jetzt eine Homepage bestellen muss. Inhaltlich zwar nicht ganz korrekt, aber im Prinzip haben sie recht, der IPv4-Adressraum wird jetzt knapp.
Wer hat das gesagt?
Wer hat das gesagt hier?
Ach, das ist schon ne Weile her, da hab ich übrigens auf dem Weg geschrieben. Na, da ging's halt darum, dass der IPv4-Adressraum knapp wird und man möchte, wenn man eine Homepage haben möchte, das Möglichste halt jetzt reaktivieren, um da halt auch noch mit da zu sein.
Was noch einfällt, welcher Kollege das erzählt hat, sag mir Bescheid, damit ich in den Ohr feigen kann.
Also, die erste Hälfte davon ist ja nicht ganz unwahr, so der IPv4-Adressraum.
Ja, das ist schon richtig, aber das hat nichts mit dem Webpage zu tun.
Das hat nichts mit den Webseiten zu tun, nein.
Kann das sein, dass du das in einem Reklamespot gehört hast? Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendeiner von meinen Kollegen hier...
Nein, nein, nein, das war Nachrichten. Also, darum geht's jetzt eigentlich gar nicht. Weil wir so eine Meme-By-Info.
Na ja, aber trotzdem, wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn wir hier Falschmeldungen rausgeben?
Also vielleicht noch, zu XML würde ich ja gern noch loswerden, dass es jetzt tatsächlich ein Standard ist in dem Sinne. Also es ist ein Standard vom W3-Konsortium. Aber es ist halt inhaltlich nicht festgelegt, was in diesem Standard ist. Also das ist im Prinzip ja nur so ein Minimalkonsens oder so was. Also da steht nur drin irgendwie...
Wie die Datei aussehen, wie das Format halt ist.
Die Syntaxe nicht, die stehen manche.
Wenn du das hier verwendest, ist es ja dein Ding halt.
Das spannende bei xml ist, dass es eben nicht verschlüsselt ist. Es ist also kein Binärformat, wo irgendwie 0, 1, irgendwelche kryptischen Zeichen drin sind, sondern es steht im Klartext für alles drin, was drin ist. Das heißt, wenn ich so eine Schnittstellenbeschreibung brauche, wenn ich nicht weiß, wie jetzt sowas abgelegt ist, dann guck ich mir diese Datei einfach an mit einem Textprogramm und kann dann sehen, wie diese Struktur aufgebaut ist von der Datei. Und die Problematik setzt aber dann an, wenn Firmen anfangen, wieder Standards auf bestimmte Satzkonstruktionen innerhalb oder in bestimmte Konstruktionen innerhalb dieser XML-Dateien zu machen. Das ist dann zwar irgendwie offen für alle, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass es denn frei verwendet werden kann. Also wir leben in einem Zeitalter, wo so schwachsinnige Sachen wie Hyperlinks irgendwie patentiert werden. Jetzt fangen die eben auch an, bestimmte ja, Layouts oder bestimmte Anordnungen von diesen Daten für sich zu patentieren oder irgendwie schützen zu lassen.
Na, ich hoffe doch nicht. Na gut, ihr habt vorhin auch K-Office angesprochen, also K-White, der eine Zirkon-Mensch, genau, war das. Das Format, das dafür benutzt wird, ist eine gezippte Tardatei, in der das drin ist.
Nee, in welchem Format speichert das?
Na, Tagizip, also ist das eine Tardatei, die gezippt wurde.
Was ist denn da drinne, was ist denn gezippt?
XML und Images.
Also wie bei Staroffice auch.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht ob Staroffice das auch so macht. Ja, und dann denke ich wird es unter Unix allgemein auch noch Latex verwendet. Das ist ziemlich oft, also jetzt außer Postscript, was ja eh mehr Verdrucker ist. Und naja, also mir hat es nur noch eingefallen. Dann der von vorhin, der ist so ziemlich nah dran, der gefragt hat, wie man ein Betriebssystem auf einer RW macht, das möglichst UDF-Dateisysteme hat. Der Linux-Kern unterstützt ab dem 2.4. zumindest experimentiell den Schreibzugriff auf UDF-Dateisysteme. Wenn man dann, wie du gesagt hast, oder jemand anderes von euch, ein Loopback-Device erstellt, dann ist das sicherlich möglich, das im Raum hat, auf CD zu schreiben.
Genau, aber Windows ist irgendwie nicht so einfach.
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Christian, wir machen Nachrichten. Danke für deinen Anruf.
Bleib ich noch drin? Okay, dann tschüss.
Wenn Fritz in Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
0, 35 nach halb eins, also quasi das Wetter. Heute Nacht bewölkt Tiefstemperatur zwischen 12 und 15 Grad. Morgen Regen bis zum Nachmittag jedenfalls. Dann kommt die Sonne raus und dann Temperaturen zwischen 20 und 26 Grad. Und hier sind die Meldungen mit Kerstin Topp.
Russland soll vollwertiges Mitglied im Kreis der wichtigsten Staaten der Welt werden und 2006 erstmals einen Weltwirtschaftsgipfel ausrichten. Dies beschlossen die G7-Staaten nach Angaben aus Delegationskreisen am Abend im kanadischen Canineskis. Bisher war Moskau bei den Weltwirtschaftsgipfeln immer nur als geladener Gast dabei. Israelische Kampfhubschrauber haben am Abend das Polizeihauptquartier in Hebron beschossen. Einwohner der Stadt berichteten, zwei Hubschrauber hätten Geschosse auf das seit Dienstag von Soldaten belagerte Gebäude abgefeuert. In dem Hauptquartier in der geteilten Stadt im Westjordanland sollen sich etwa 15 von Israel gesuchte Extremisten verschanzt haben. Unionskanzler Kandidat Stoiber hat mehr Leistung und mehr Wettbewerb in Deutschland gefordert. In einer Grundsatzrede im Französischen Dom in Berlin plädierte er außerdem dafür, bürokratische Hürden abzubauen. International werde Deutschland inzwischen mit Verkrustung und Unbeweglichkeit gleichgesetzt, sagte Stoiber. Matthias Platzek ist neuer Ministerpräsident von Brandenburg. Der bisherige Potsdamer Oberburger Meister wurde heute vom Landtag gewählt. Platzek tritt die Nachfolge von Stoiber an, der am Sonnabend überraschend seinen Rücktritt verkündet hatte. Bei der Fußballweltmeisterschaft spielt Deutschland im Finale gegen Brasilien. Die Brasilianer gewannen gegen die Türkei mit 1 zu 0. Das Endspiel wird am Sonntag um 13 Uhr angepfiffen. Und die Verkehrsmeldungen A100, Berlin-Wilmersdorf, Berlin-Wedding. Zwischen Spandauer Damm und Beusselstraße ist wegen einer Baustelle der linken Fahrstreifen gesperrt.
Der Fritz Love Parade Countdown, mit allem, was du schon immer mal über die Love Parade wissen wolltest, was du immer schon mal hören wolltest und vor allen Dingen, was du schon immer der Love Parade sagen wolltest. Außerdem mit Love Parade Party Tipps und im Radio mit mir, Anja Schneider, jeden Samstag 19 bis 20 Uhr. Bis zur Love Parade. Pritz!
Ich komm dich zu holen.
Chaosradio 73, ein paar Minuten haben wir noch bis eins. Dann geht's weiter mit Martin Piersdorf. Und wir telefonieren weiter. So, hallo Sieben, hallo Stefan.
Hallo. Ja und zwar, ich wollte einfach mal sagen, dass auch Standards zum Problem für Firmen werden können. Also gerade wenn Firmen selber Standards beschließen und dann ja feststellen, oh Gott, der Standard wurde geknackt. Gerade jetzt bei DVDs oder so, wo man gerade feststellt, ja, dass man die Daten also auch runterritten kann und in andere Formate, also MPEG, AW, DISX, wie auch immer, umsetzen kann und dass das dann ja zum Problem wird, also dass sich auch Firmen selber ein Alkentor damit schießen können.
Das ist regelmäßig zu beobachten, ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber eine andere Art und Weise, wie Firmen das auch umsetzen, dass sie sich zum Beispiel gerade, wie die Firma Rambus das versucht hat, sich in Normungsgremien einfinden, also mit der Yedek zusammenführen.
Ganz kurz, Rambus ist das ist ein Bus für Speicher, für Speicherzugrenze. Das heißt also, wie die Speicherchips auf meinem Board mit meiner CPU verbunden sind.
Das ist die Firma, die mit Intel zusammengearbeitet hat und diesen schnellen Speicher für den Pentium 4 zusammen gebastelt hatte. Und die hat zusammen im Namen von Normungsgremien, also das nennt sich Yedek, zusammen also ein Standard verabschiedet, der an diesen Speicher, gerade auf Rambo Speicherebene funktioniert und hintenrum, also hinter Rückzahl Rambos, das Verfahren für diesen Speicher auf sich patentiert und alle anderen Firmen, die dann diesen Standard mitnutzen wollten oder auch Sachen für Intel anbieten wollten, also Pentium 4 zum Beispiel, die haben dann natürlich in Anführungsstrichen eine Arschkarte gehabt.
Bei einigen Standardsorganisationen ist es so üblich, dass die sich dagegen absichern, also die EZI zum Beispiel, das Europäische Normungsgremium für Telekommunikation, die haben dann spezielle Klauseln, dass Standards auf jeden Fall non-discriminatory access to intellectual property bieten müssten, dass also wirklich jeder die Patente dann auch für wenig Geld bekommen kann, dass da keiner vom Markt ausgeschlossen werden kann, so weiter und so fort. Andere haben das offensichtlich nicht, wie die JDAC offensichtlich. Und natürlich spielt Hersteller das Spiel, das probieren echt viele da schnell nochmal irgendwas unterzubringen. Sie tun es auf verschiedenen Größenordnungen, also Rambus war da sicherlich auch besonders dreister Fall.
Ja, ich finde, es ist überhaupt, generell spielt es momentan beim Marketing bei Firmen sowieso eine Rolle, bevor die überhaupt ihr Produkt rausbringen, wie viel Geld sie dann an, nicht nur mit dem Produkt machen können, sondern wie viel Geld sie auch allein mit den Patenten, also mit dem, was sie dann letztendlich schützen, wie sie sie damit verdienen, spielt ja immer mehr mit rein. Also ich finde, es ist ja auch gerade, wenn man so sieht, wie Patente angemeldet werden, die auch erst am Anfang noch nicht standardkonform sind und dann einfach zum Standard gemacht werden, das ist ja unnormal. Man wird ja mit Standard momentan bombardiert, ohne Ende. Jeder bietet einen Standard an und sagt, der ist es. Und der, der sich letztendlich dann durchsetzt, das ist dann immer eine Frage, woher soll man das wissen? Ich finde, das ist das eigentliche. Diesen Wald, den müsste man irgendwie mal aufräumen. Dass man nicht mehr mit Standards bombardiert wird, sondern dass man einer wirklich sagt, festlegt, das ist der Standard.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es nicht vielleicht besser, wenn es da so eine Art evolutionären Druck gibt, dass irgendwie sich der durchsetzt, der tatsächlich besser ist. Also ein Standard wird doch nicht dadurch zum Standard, dass man erklärt, dass es ein Standard ist, sondern dass die Leute ihn benutzen. Und wenn man halt irgendwie was Schlechtes zum Standard erklärt, dann benutzen es die Leute hinterher nicht, es ist keinem geholfen, sondern es ist viel besser, wenn es eine Alternative für gibt.
Naja, aber andersrum, wenn man so hört von großen Firmen, die sich ja immer wieder irgendwo durchsetzen und immer irgendwie Druck machen, die andere mit sich in ihren Bann ziehen, indem sie sich gegenseitig mit Patenten, ich sag mal gegenseitig, absichern, wo dann vier, fünf große sagen, okay, das ist der Standard, und die kleinen außenrum dann gar nicht mehr rankommen. Dann finde ich, das ist das irgendwo schon nicht mehr, ich sag mal, der kleine Mann, der kriegt dann aufgedrückt und der benutzt es, genauso wie alle Microsoft benutzen und Windows benutzen, wird es dann eher von den Großen aufgedrückt. Also ich finde, eine richtig freie Entscheidung, dass man sagen kann, okay, die Leute, ich sag mal, wie bei MP3 das passiert ist, sowas hat man relativ selten, dass die große Masse dann entscheidet, okay, das ist es. Wenn man bloß eine gewisse Sache vorgelegt kriegt, ja, dann greift man zu, wenn man keine andere Wahl hat. Also ich finde, ganz frei ist das nicht. Also ganz demokratisch kann man da nicht sagen, dass der Beste sich durchsetzt. Also ich finde, dass gerade von solchen großen Firmen immer wieder irgendwo hintenrum, was zum Standard erklärt wird und andere anderen ziehen dann mit, weil sie gar keine andere Wahl haben. Also von daher ist es richtig. Ja, was soll man großartig sagen? Also ich finde, das ist das einzig Traurige dabei. Und da freut es mich dann umso mehr, dass sich ab und zu dann einige Firmen dann auch mal ein Eigentor schießen. Gerade wie das mit dieser DVD-Geschichte ist, dass man also Filme auch weitergeben kann, ohne dass man jetzt eben noch mal eine neue DVD kauft.
Also dazu ist vielleicht noch anzumerken, dass es eigentlich ja jetzt möglich ist, diese DVDs abzuspielen oder zu kopieren. Das war eigentlich gar nicht die ursprüngliche Intention oder also nicht unbedingt die, sondern die Idee war eigentlich, dass man DVDs auch unter Linux oder unter anderen Betriebssystemen abspielen kann. Und das Problem ist aber, dass du einfach für Linux diese Lizenz auch nicht gekriegt hast für diesen Player. Also für die, um das alles zu implementieren. Das heißt, die Leute waren einfach gezwungen, wenn sie auf Linux DVDs gucken wollten, die mussten dieses Ding einfach knacken. Es führte kein Weg dran vorbei, weil du hast einfach keine Lizenz gekriegt.
Ja gut, also wie gesagt, also das muss ich zum Beispiel auch nicht. Das ist ganz mal dran zu hören. Wie gesagt, was wird der denn in der Regel auch ausgenutzt? Na gut, das wollte ich einfach nur dazu sagen. Ich wünsche dir noch einen schönen Abend.
Danke, gleichfalls.
Na klar.
Und guten Abend Boris.
Ja, wenn ich das so höre, dann wird mir ganz anders, weil ich hab von diesen ganzen Standards überhaupt keine Ahnung. Du, ich auch nicht. Ich ruf eigentlich nur an, weil ich ein ganz großes Problem mit meinem neuen Computer eigentlich habe und zwar ich hab mich für einen neuen.
Es geht aber doch um Standards.
Ja, aber vielleicht sei er ja so eine Software Experten und Hardware Experten, hätte ja sein können, dass er mir vielleicht helfen könnte bei meinem kleinen Problem.
Und zwar kriegt mein Computer nicht mehr runtergefahren.
Also der fährt zwar runter und dann bleibt halt bei diesem XP, bei diesem ganz tollen neuen Windows XP bleibt halt die blaue Oberfläche zum Schluss. Und dann fährt er halt nicht mehr von alleine runter.
Das könnte zum Beispiel daran liegen, dass sich irgendwie der Hersteller der Software oder auch der Hardware nicht an eine bestimmte Norm, zum Beispiel die ACPI Norm gehalten hat, die unter anderem so Sachen wie das runterfahren und ausschalten von Computern regelt. Das könnte ein Grund dafür sein. Aber da können wir jetzt ja nicht wirklich weiterhelfen, weil wir nicht genau wissen, wie Microsoft ACPI implementiert hat. Und das ist irgendwie auch so eine Intel Nummer. Und dann ist es zwar irgendwie offen und dokumentiert irgendwie, aber ich glaube nicht alle Sachen oder so was. Da hat doch bestimmt Intel auch den Daumen drauf.
Also ACPI ist auch ein ganz furchtbar komplexer Standard mit irgendwelchen Skripten, die im BIOS stehen und dann ausgeführt werden von Betriebssystemen. Und das funktioniert alles nur so halb. Also ich würde dir empfehlen, das Gerät einfach dahin zu tragen, wo du es gekauft hast, um zu erklären, es geht nicht aus.
Ja, wäre natürlich eine einfache Möglichkeit sowieso. Ja, ich meine, es hören ja nicht nur hier Fachleute zu. Also wie gesagt, es hören ja auch Leute zu, die nicht so die Ahnung darüber haben. Und deswegen dachte ich, man kann es auch anrufen.
Guck mal im Netz bei Google, Windows fährt nicht runter.
Alles klar.
Okay, viel Glück noch, Boris. Und hallo Marco.
Ja hallo, ich habe ein Problem.
Ich habe mir jetzt über Kabel Internet geholt, habe Windows 2nd Edition 98 und jedenfalls hatte ich den Internet Explorer 5.0. Mit dem ging es einmal frei, habe einmal frei Verbindungen gekriegt, habe dann den 6.0 runtergeladen und seitdem kriege ich keine Verbindung zum Internet mehr. Könnte mir da irgendwie helfen oder müsste ich dann den 5.0 installieren?
Vielleicht solltest du erstmal testen, ob das Internet nicht geht oder der Browser nicht geht.
Also er sagt mir dann Server nicht gefunden oder DNS Fehler.
Proxy, das garantiert ein Proxy, das garantiert irgendeinen scheiß Proxy eingestellt und der geht nicht. Hast du mal die Anleitung gelesen?
Inwiefern?
Naja, F1 drücken, dann geht ein Fenster auf und da ist erklärt, wie die Software funktioniert, die du benutzt. Und da guckst du mal nach Proxy und nach DNS.
Oder Alt-F4.
Da wäre ich mir nicht sicher. Drück mal F1, mach den Browser auf, drück F1 und dann guckst du mal nach Proxys und nach DNS.
Naja, ich bin gerade auf Arbeit, also hier ist schlecht. Alles klar.
Das ist auch der einzige Rat, den wir dir geben können. Es ist immer das Problem, darum sind solche Anrufe, Entschuldigung, relativ nützlos, wenn man nicht davor sitzt, ist Ferndiagnose quasi unmöglich.
Du kannst es aber auch in Google oder in eine andere Lieblings-Suchmaschine eingeben, einfach Internet Explorer, Update und geht nicht oder so.
Viel Glück damit Marco. So, das letzte Wort zumindest am Telefon hat Daniel. Hallo Daniel. Probleme mit Windows?
Nee, ich wollte noch mal ein Wort zu XMF verlieren. Und zwar ist es ja bekannt, dass es ja im Grunde genommen menschlich lesbar ist, dass man ja deshalb auch das Format relativ gut analysieren kann und theoretisch auch dann sozusagen von, weiß ich nicht, von Open Office nach Carver das Ganze überführen kann mit XSLT. Allerdings, ich sag mal, hindert ja niemand, niemand daran, Microsoft zum Beispiel, dass die ihre Daten letzten Endes doch binär da irgendwo reinpacken. Aber ich glaube, irgendwie diese BS64-Codierung oder so kann man das ja doch machen, dass man auch Binärdaten unterbringen kann. Also es holt mich nicht wundern, wenn die das letzten Ende so machen.
Du meinst, dass sie einfach eine Word-Datei nehmen und die in XML-Binary-Object reintun?
Irgendwie sowas in der Art, also, weiß ich nicht. Das trau ich denen noch zu.
So was in der Art hab ich neulich mal gesehen. Das war nicht mit Word, aber es war irgendwie, wo stand neu, jetzt XML-kompatibel und dann haben sie tatsächlich einfach bloß ihr altes Datenformat mit einem Beginn- und einem Endtag davor und dahinter.
Ja, so ungefähr.
So ist es natürlich nicht gedacht.
Also ich glaub nicht, dass sie das so weit öffnen, dass man das einfach so einfach transformieren kann, irgendwas anderes, das wär ja zu einfach.
Sie werden müssen, denk ich.
Ja, ansonsten was Standards generell noch angeht, also ich mach mir manchmal so den Spaß und guck mir dann mal so die HTML Seiten an, so lass die mal durch den Validator durchjagen. Also was da so normal vorauskommt, da stehen mir schon irgendwo die Haare zu Berge, dass ich die Leute einfach nicht an HTML4 halten kann. Ganz schweig von nichts, HTML ist schon irgendwie ziemlich traurig.
Gut, aber das ist ja nicht ein Problem des Standards, sondern der Leute oder so.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber naja gut.
Aber es ist schön, dass es da so ein Tool gibt, wo ich dann den Standard überprüfen kann, also wo ich dann überprüfen kann, ob ich mich denn an den Standard halte.
Ansonsten kann ich nur inständig hoffen, dass ich SVG gegenüber Flash irgendwie durchsetze noch. Sieht zwar im Moment auch nicht so aus, aber ich hoffe es ist irgendwie inständig.
Toll, jetzt hast du uns den Abend verdorben. Er hat das F-Wort gesagt.
Deshalb denke ich auch, SVG ist da schon die beste Alternative, die offen ist und zum Beispiel XML basiert und mit den entsprechenden Vorteilen die XML so bietet.
Bei Flash muss ich immer an dieses Queen Stück denken.
Kennste das?
Flash!
Genau. Ja, ich hör jetzt auf zu singen und wir hören jetzt auf zu telefonieren Daniel. Wir sind wieder am Ende. Danke für deinen Anruf. Gute Nacht.
So, vielleicht nochmal wie ihr uns erreicht, nämlich wenn ihr irgendwie Feedback zur Sendung habt, wenn ihr Nachfragen habt, jetzt zu dieser Sendung, nicht allgemein zu Fritz Chaos Radio, sondern genau zu dieser Sendung, zu diesem Thema, schreibt an 73 at chaosradio. ctc.de 73 at chaosradio.
ctc.de Genau und morgen ab dem frühen Nachmittag gibt es unter www.fritz.de die ganze Sendung auch nochmals MP3 zum Nachhören. Gestattet mir bitte auszuschlafen, bevor ich mich an den Digitizer setze hier. Haben wir noch was vergessen?
Ja, es gibt eine sehr makabere Norm in unseren Augen, nämlich einen normierten Abhörstandard innerhalb von Europa. Der ist von diesem EZI Gremium, diesem europäischen Gremium für Normung in der Telekommunikation festgelegt worden. Und der erleichtert also das europaweite, länderübergreifende Abhören von Telefonaten und von Datenleitungen. Da ist jetzt ein bisschen was durchgesickert irgendwie. Das ist alles schon komplett gemacht. Da sitzen Geheimdienstler auch mit in den Gremien drin, wenn wir das mal so sagen können. Und das ist also eigentlich ein sehr makaberer Standard.
Aber das benutzt man ja nur, wenn der Richter das erlaubt hat. Natürlich. Das war das Chaosradio 73. Standards war das Thema. Vielen Dank, Frank. Vielen Dank, Andreas. Vielen Dank, Angler. Ein paar Minuten darfst du laufen lassen noch. Musik, wie gesagt, live aufgelegt vom Angler zu erreichen unter www.antennenkinder.de und auch live zum Tanzen zu sehen. Wo war das, Frank?
Das war im Metronom Berlin-Lichtenberg.
Wenn es wieder aufmacht.
Wenn es wieder aufmacht im Metronom in Lichtenberg. Hier geht es weiter mit Night Flight Martin-Petersdorf in fünf Minuten. Bis dahin noch ein bisschen Musik vom Angler. Vielen Dank, dass ihr bei uns geblieben seid.
Tschüss.
Das nächste Chaos Radio, also die 74 am letzten Mittwoch im Juli.
Wir machen weiter.
Wir sind dort anders.
Wir machen weiter. Das kommt von der See.
Kommt aus die Leiter.
Wir machen ein Traum. Let's go!